to
what is up people of the
world it's july 13th
wednesday
[Music]
[Applause]
come on piggy
come on down now when my friend neil
bent over this
[Music]
what do we do about it
what are we gonna do about it
what do we do about it
wow
when my friend neil bent over man what
are we gonna do about it
today's episode is sponsored by honey
liquid iv and stamps.com
you know i'm never gonna let howie live
that down
as long as i know him
we've been texting a bit i wanted him to
call in to talk about it but he's laying
low on the prolapse
what do we do about it what are we gonna
do about it
and then i introduce him to um
our
our ad agency
um
what's your intro that was the best
email ever thanks bro yeah yeah he well
he just asked who what do i uh who do i
work with for ads and i and i i love the
guys we work with and i said would you
like an intro he said sure so here's the
email i wrote
hey alan introing you to one and only
howie mendel has an incredible podcast i
have the number one most viewed episode
of all time on his podcast that's
important context i mean it is right
yeah absolutely
you know
i wanted to intro you guys as i'm sure
you have plenty to discuss that being
said
i'm not sure how ad friendly howie is
if you've seen his recent tick tock with
that prolapsed anus but i think he's
mostly clean cheers
what do we do about it
i love i love that it's my favorite meme
it's such a shame i can't like post it
more but howie mandela posting a
product's anus is something we can't
forget in 2022. go over this happened
big talk of the year
i mean yeah easily for sure yeah easily
so that's what's up did i thank our
sponsors you did all three of them
god i hope so
honey liquidity and stamps.com
there's no leftovers tomorrow by the way
hassan is um
in europe or some [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] i mean i don't know he's in
europe right
yes yeah mr [ __ ] is one keeping helping
of a man
oh exactly wow in
europe doing a flight simulator
i heard he didn't he's not learning how
to land if you know what i mean
yeah he almost crashed
you know what i'm saying mm-hmm yeah
[Music]
i wonder what this does
[Applause]
that simulator looks so legit it's so
awesome yeah that looks awesome
wow
so there you go he's having a good time
out there and uh well that's all that
matters to me is that he's happy you
know what i mean yeah absolutely
um
i want to do that though that looks so
dope that must be how they really train
pilots before they go up you know
so i have to interrupt someone donated
500 dollars the heck
message
with no message
is it our saudi benefactor no it's not
uh
no yeah
thank you uh thank you king or queen
brian
thank you daddy mommy
whoever you are no message you're not
even looking for clout
what
what a king and or queen
daddy
or non-specified gender or or not or not
any sort of noble at all a non-binary
royal person yeah just like just a royal
person you know
you love that
what's their name
brian
i just says brian
there's a last name too i forgot what it
said brian brian
there you go thanks ryan shout out to
your family
did you say
brian brian it's very close
he's like i'll give you 500 bucks you
get man get my name right
um you know there was a new report came
out today inflation is at 9.1 percent
oh wait that's bad news isn't it which
is scary but i'll tell you what
while um
inflation's at nine point one percent
teddy fresh is on sale for fifty percent
starting tomorrow man let's [ __ ] go
see where
so that it's really only a forty one
percent sale then if you if accounted
for inflation yes but it's still a good
deal
[Music]
you know
but that's what i'm saying we're saying
[ __ ] inflation bro
um
we are doing tomorrow at
10 a.m pacific time
50 off the whole goddamn website except
for the gentle thrills one which just
came out
what did we do about it yeah
yeah
and um
so yeah make sure to get on the website
tomorrow at 10 a.m if you want something
stuff tends to go pretty fast on these
sales
but uh
times are tough so we said you know
let's just give people an opportunity to
get some teddy fresh
in a good wholesome way
i made this meme do you like it
you made that meme yep
elon musk could never
he doesn't make his own meaning bro i
don't go to non gag i make this [ __ ] in
my meme laboratory wow i'm making meats
now smoking these meats here no means no
end of the world
50 off teddy fresh meat i guess another
one could be like 9.1 percent inflation
did you present teddy fresh me uh oh
back to the lab
so anyway that's going on tomorrow very
exciting
stuff
um today we have to talk about a few
things there's more ace fest drama
we are out here
defending ace family i have to say we
are ace family stands die hard
absolutely
i mean i said something minus minor
criticism austin you guys jumped down my
throat
yeah ian was ready to throw the watch
out
dude
have you deleted the content core yet
that one's still uh it's still up but
but i will say that was pre ace fest oh
my god i'm gonna sue for what if he sees
that i'm so embarrassed what if austin
sees that
it's pre ace fest guys i'm just saying
thank you aien was right he defended
acevedo yes he was right
i wanted to get rid of like all that bad
energy i tell you what if they come on
the show i'll erase the uh content
that's a pretty good deal right yeah
i'm so tired
i didn't sleep last night i couldn't
sleep last night freaking annoying we're
energetically aligned what time did you
go to bed like
four in the morning yeah but i was like
in bed at like 1 30. i was tossing and
turning for a long time it's just oh god
i hate not getting sleep [ __ ] my whole
day up man i feel horrible
[Music]
was there something on your mind dan are
you just tossing and turning
yeah i
saw that the [ __ ] content court was
still open oh
yeah
we better we better remove that i want
we need you to get some sleep
[Music]
this is judge ethan i am declaring i am
a commuting
ace family sentence i hereby
acquit them of all charges
this is a pro ace family show
please
please austin i'm looking for a new
bestie just reach out
[Music]
anyway
so we're going to talk about that um
jeff and mike are still fighting over
who wants to be my bestie meanwhile i
just want to be friends with austin
we have a really interesting call at 2
p.m
that i don't want to spoil
but yeah we have one of the top
political minds calling in at 2 p.m to
give us an insight
on something really really interesting
why
you're not going to want to miss that i
guarantee it no okay stop bro
[ __ ] mind your own business jordan
peterson the jews what
what's the context of that jordan the
way you said that was not cool he has a
new video out where he is addressing um
the muslims of the world
yes and uh really yeah he put out a
whole declaration for all the muslims
well he he he i believe correct me if
i'm wrong maybe but he has actually
solved the sunni shia uh division yes
he's actually a prophet yeah and i refer
to him now as shaq peterson please
in a book prophet jordan yeah prophet
how did you hear that one prophet jp in
a book in a book huh huh
what the hell
oh man we just got another 50 gifted
subs from
the bff chlor
season two
episode three well that's deep co i
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
but i appreciate it
is there any good jordan oh oh no i get
what they're saying oh that's an
interesting suggestion the bff chiller
it's like the bachelor but for who gets
to be your bff yeah but season two
episode three well i think they're just
memes but that that that could be it
that is a good
so so we would have jeff austin and mike
all competing to be my friend you could
go on little little little dates with
them oh that's brilliant wendy williams
one on one
howie
i think we could be best friends
after what we do about it after that pro
what do we do about it
so anyway we got a whole bunch of stuff
to talk about by the way
is there a new jordan peterson video we
should be watching because you know i
love that man
there is
i mean maybe watched it it's just
i mean it wasn't as like meme worthy
really yeah
i was hoping it was he did an interview
with this guy kyle kalinski who is a um
progressive
uh youtuber i'm kind of surprised dude
he looks so dark bro what happened
that all meat diet is like [ __ ] up
his skin
also he's so dark and brooding now it's
like
straight up joker vibes especially with
that green shirt he's turning into a
lobster
yeah right the final transformation just
like the movie
it's a new batman villain called the
lobster
he's best friends with the penguin
all right it's five minutes let's see if
there's anything good here
the question is
is the physician really criminal if you
agree that adults can decide to train
he's asking so you guys know jordan said
that
elliott page's physician is a criminal
for
doing a gender affirming procedure on a
adult 35 year old years old that was the
crime yeah let's see what he says about
that transition then why would the
physician be criminal don't adults have
that right if they want to transition
taking too long on that one buddy
a pretty simple question
i mean this is this is honestly
yeah drum roll this is like
a civil rights issue and they don't
realize how [ __ ] wrong they are and
on the wrong side history it's
incredible you know this is like from
the 50s so do you think black people
should have the same uh drinking
fountain as a white folks and then
jordan's like
you know i'm gonna have to get back to
you on that one i mean it's really that
[ __ ] up what they're doing here where
he goes with it is actually
right
i mean this is what we're seeing right
here is just like open
and hostile and violent bigotry it's
incredible
not everything legal isn't criminal not
everything legal isn't criminal for
example one time
oh
oh oh
well finger on the wall
i had a prescription to xanax okay just
because i abused it
now is it criminal for me to go to a
to a drug dealer and get more xanax
because my doctor wasn't prescribing
enough i mean i had the prescription
i think what he meant
to say is not everything legal is more
yeah yeah
that would make more sense i did not
come on my door i think everything not
everything that's
allowed is
moral right so you're saying i did not
want my dick anywhere near my door
listen
technically you're allowed to put your
dick on your dog at what point does it
become bestiality i gently rested it on
my dog's butthole
is that criminal i don't know not
necessarily i didn't penetrate my dog it
just rested there i've never done
anything weird with my dog i'm just
making a point
what if
i forgot to do his voice
kermit kermit kermit
i think that what if
what if my dog just happened to walk on
top of me and his dick went in my mouth
i was taking a nap
it's not necessarily criminal is it
buddy
but it doesn't make it right
but i still did it this bit suffers i
woke up and the dog's dick was in my
mouth
red rocket and everything
now did i suck it
i don't know i tried to spit it out but
he's a big dog
but i don't care
i tried to spit it out and spit it out
but it just wouldn't go out
is that does that make me a criminal
i don't know buckle
call the police see what happens
i let her have her way no all right but
my grandma
brushed her pubes on my face does that
make her a criminal
there i'm in trouble again
i love that this guy's the the prominent
right thinker it's so awesome
not everything moral is criminal bucko
one time i accidentally [ __ ] on my
dog's butthole sex he just walked up to
me sex what the [ __ ] is this in my
post-coital phase
in
how did you pull that up so far that is
good
i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets about that no i i
[ __ ] on my dog and i had some
post-coital regrets is it illegal though
to jizz on your own dog
i did not come on my dog i
did come on my dog i did not [ __ ] my dog
i did [ __ ] my dog all right let's keep
watching
my dog i just love making fun you are
such a bigot [ __ ] loser bro how about
you mind your own business you dumbass
like your life like your life is so
[ __ ] up you talk about clean your own
room bro you look like
you're on hospice care bro and i mean
that with peace and love i'm just saying
like just get your own life together yes
talking about elliot page bro
not everything legal isn't criminal
i love that that's what he came up with
after that i would have left
long long pause and then just something
that totally doesn't make any sense
well i know what he's saying he's saying
just because it's legal doesn't mean
it's right right but he doesn't say he
didn't even say it well
he [ __ ] up his his words there
jalone if she hadn't been parading her
new abs in a fashion magazine
parade how many kids do you think she
can convince to convert
she's she's trying to convince kids to
convert
god
dude you're awesome i'm only can i'm
only concerned about the kids
for example my daughter she's very well
adjusted she traveled europe with cobra
tate a known human trafficker
i'd much rather that than have her tits
cut off
you once yeah
no not yeah no no
i want to respond to that i think that
with the trans community it's very
similar to the gay community where back
when that first became a big issue
people thought oh if we talk about it if
it's in magazines or whatever we're
promoting kids to go down that path
preach really what happened is
people are who they are
they just decided to be like yeah
what yeah
no we never talked about gay people
there wouldn't exist yeah he thinks you
can spread
yeah yo so when i called him out for
being pro-conversion therapy a lot of
his like um loyalists were like that's
not what he meant yeah but it is what he
meant it's 100
yo
he's even worse than i thought
yep
holy [ __ ] dude
hey and they were just more open and
honest with themselves so i don't think
you're promoting people to do that
did he really just say that we shouldn't
say gay people shouldn't be open about
being gay because it makes more people
gay you really just said that he
believes that you
that it spreads
yeah but it's a corruption of people's
spirits and morality and that by
society being accepting
uh of them you know but hold on more
people will become gay this is dr
jordan peterson phd
um who's basically got the philosophy
now of kenneth copeland i mean
tuba
demons and tuba demons percentage of the
population do you think uh in your
conception of how this is unfolding what
percentage of the population do you
think
is going to end up being trans at the
end of this do you think like
all of them
now
identifies to use that hated word
identifies it as part of the
hypothetical lgbtq plus community
one in five that seems high
no i mean that that may be true
not trans he's saying yeah lbg deep
just yeah yeah yeah not okay okay that
sounds about right to me yeah
and and and the problem is what jordan
you know what i mean and that's this
affects you how
so it's one in five i don't know what
the upper limit is there's a consulting
group in the uk now that's claiming
there's 150 different genders there's
actually i suppose seven billion
different genders if you want to get
technical about it because everybody's
temperament differs
but i don't know what the upper limit is
and i have no idea what the upper limit
is for this surgical intervention we'll
see doesn't but i don't find it i don't
find it the least bit acceptable and if
you i'm coming for your dick jordan
i'm going to cut it off and you're going
to love it
you're going to consent to it bucko
who thinks oh yeah guys give it up for
pride minute everybody this is our
pride minute so
can we fly the rainbow flag to get the
clock going jordan peterson
he sanctioned pride minute so everybody
just
you know be proud who you are i'm just
gonna admire dan's blue eyes for a
second oh yeah yeah it's time to do it
baby big ass blue eyes just be proud
okay stop
now be ashamed
you guys are gay as [ __ ]
shame on you pride minute is over all
right back to the pride is a sin pride
is a sim that's right [ __ ] you're all
going to hell for that minute
fools it was a trick shame
it was a trap
rainbow flags in the chat
and now can we get crosses in the chat
guys for jesus
because now we need a minute of prayer
yeah we need to go oh jesus
you only get one minute of rainbows and
the rest is jesus guys so crosses please
is demanding that you extend your uh
pity
to the lgbtq
plus community
at the cost of sterilizing children
[Music]
you should think again you're on the
wrong side of this and not in a trivial
way yeah but as a star
and a public figure and a model for
emulation
she also has the responsibility not to
entice confused adolescents and do a
catastrophic decision before they have
the maturity to make that decision
i just have to say jordan i think it's a
little bit of a moral panic i just don't
see some sort of
you know
frenzy okay what would you consider
become trans what first of all that's a
hell of a way to put it
what why don't you take a look at the
increases in surgical interventions and
see what you think i mean how many do
you think is too many i'm getting these
look if we're talking about i'll answer
your question i'll answer your question
the argument is it it used to be very
repressed because that's very outside of
the tradition and the norm and it's so
obvious i mean we've looked at the chart
of like left-handed people
it maxes out at like 12 which is you
know
basically the the ex
the baseline organic percentage of
people that that end up that way it's
the same with
with uh homosexuality and it's going to
end up being the same thing with with
people who identify as transgender
you know it's not rocket science but
anyway enough of that jordan peterson's
lost
i'll catch you guys next time on pride
minute
i'm trying to find the source on
the one in five that's
a little bit
in my opinion i found the i think i
found it nearly one in five young adults
say they are not straight
global survey fines
okay i mean
all right cheers guys enjoy your pride
minute
105 everybody
pride minute
so anyway moving on jordan peterson uh
maybe
you uh
almost died at sizzler i heard
you went and also you went to red
lobster recently on the way back then
you're at sizzler there's some kind of
weird
thing i'm noticing was red lobster your
idea
no it wasn't okay
i forget whose idea it was the sizzlers
like red lobster right i'm not the same
vibe yeah i wasn't
no no because there's not as nice as red
lobster we should probably explain what
sizzler is too because apparently it's
not a national thing yeah i didn't know
what it was what yeah abe didn't know
what it was uh i think sam said to be
honest with you i've never heard of it
no i don't think i've ever been to a
sizzler
i'll never go back i'll tell you that
was the food good at least
the few bites that i had were decent so
tell me what happened at sizzler you
poor son of a gun uh there's not much to
tell you kind of be there but i just
started choking
and it was the most embarrassing like 10
minutes of my life
10 minutes of choking is that oh yeah
that was a good 10 minutes no one was
helping me except lena was like freaking
out hitting my back
i tried drinking water to wash it down
and every time i tried to drink water i
would project the water like the
exorcist so i was literally puking all
over the restaurant i puked on our
phones on our food on my shirt and
everyone's just looking at me like i'm
[ __ ] crazy no one's helping me okay
way back you're just blown away blown
away that nobody
everybody was just like looking over at
this guy like just projectile vomiting
all over the place and like oh boy wait
okay
back it up first of all you're right i'm
searching the usa i don't see sizzler
anywhere but socal yeah i guess
what fridge i thought it it had some
cultural uh
heft to it because i i i see it being
made fun of in in media sometimes you
know oh no i see some sizzlers okay
there's some sizzlers in idaho utah new
mexico we got some in
texas
uh but it is not
and it's not everywhere what so what is
sizzler uh ab let's start there well
there's some messages in the group chat
that dan put in the album but my food is
in there
it's like okay old country buffet meets
like
hell i don't know
wait it's a buffet it's so it's it's
like a weird hybrid you go into the city
it's a buffet it's not oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
but that looks like a nice plate of food
right there maybe yeah so i was saying
26 bucks i'm living like a king
he's like all i know is
that was almost my last message to the
world
all i know is i'm eating like a king
this is why i had to share
minutes before tragedy yeah all i know
is i'm eating like a king and then if
you scroll down just like 10 minutes
later
i feel like i've heard uh yada yada
um yada yada says the rules blah blah
blah how'd you like it scizzler almost
killed me
okay ten minutes later
that was like the most embarrassing 10
minutes can i make an observation yeah
this lobster looks like howie's
prolapsed
i gotta tell you
the lobster tail like stuck to it like
the hard
shell
yeah what do we do about it like when
you get some
eggshell in your eggs it was yeah okay
so you get the food now how is it like
hometown buffet you order right you just
order off the map you go in and pay
first you order a first you pay it first
it's like a hybrid it's there's really
nothing like this what it's really like
like
yeah you walk up bottom of the barrel
down you walk up and it's kind of like
ordering at a fast food restaurant okay
essentially but then they give you a
number and you bring it to the table and
then from that point on you have like a
waiter that comes and serves you oh my
god no then there's a vegas buffet but
then yeah there's like a salad bar which
is i guess you know just you can free
refills on the on the salad drink
machines right someone says sizzlers the
mcdonald's of fine dining there you have
it right there you go yeah
wow okay that's really interesting so
you got yourself a nice looking steak
potato and a prolapsed lobster correct
we do about it
so you start eating how many but what do
you eat first i ate the lobster first i
was curious you enjoyed the lobster it
was okay you finished the whole thing
okay you ate the whole lobster down and
then what was next the steak and i had
about three bites you had three bites
and it got stuck prior the first few
were a little hard to get down but i
always have trouble no was it a problem
with the steak or is this a a b problem
so i i do need to have a drink with me
when i eat because i do get stuff kind
of stuck but i have i've only choked
three times in my life in total the
other two times were in high school is
this a problem you're not chewing your
food enough or is this you have a petite
little throat
yeah you got a tight little throat yeah
you got a [ __ ] little boy yeah
sam suggested maybe i lube up the steak
next time oh
i got to tell you in love you'll
appreciate this ab is anti-sauce a b
doesn't sauce things
and he keeps choking and i'm saying you
got to lube up your food dude a little
bit now you got a tight little throat
like that let me let me ask you lina
does he not chew his food why is he
choking on steak all the time
i don't know what it is but yeah he it's
not the first time he's choked it
happens
and never this bad but it happens
regularly
and so did you think he was gonna die
was it that bad no i i brought on my
phone actually at first i was like
chuckling and i was gonna record and
then when i noticed how serious it was
um i put it down and i got up to help
him did you have any footage of it not
at all i wish i wish i recorded just a
little bit and then how did you hope
when were you doing the heimlich no
trying to burp me like a baby oh you're
just pounding his back i'm like stop
stop yeah because no one else was
helping and i didn't know what to do
there one of the waitresses comes up she
goes are you choking are you okay are
you choking i'm like i'm joking and then
she's like okay she goes in the back
she's like i never saw it i'll call
9-1-1
to come get your body well first of all
amy can i suggest smaller bites and more
chewing okay your life is on the line
yeah yeah definitely
and i did i just didn't want to die in
sizzler man i was like i went outside
into the street i was like i'm going to
die let it be in the streets
not
sizzler
and so you're chewing the stick
now now it got it it's totally clogged
in your throat okay are you you can't
breathe or you could breathe i can't
breathe i couldn't even i kind of get
watered down nothing that's what really
scared me because in the past when i've
choked the water still went down i just
didn't get the food down okay and so
you're choking you're freaking out it's
stuck in your throat you're trying to
drink water you're spitting out water
are you standing or sitting standing
literally standing going
everywhere and everyone's just looking
at everybody in the sizzler is watching
you
and you it's incredible how nobody
actually went to help with the heimlich
you what do we do about it you know what
else is so [ __ ]
in my mind i'm thinking
man this would be a funny ass video but
it
oh that's some vlog yeah do you regret
that lena tried to help you instead of
film it no no it was it was
it was sweet you could see in her eye
when she was kind of like smiling at
first and then when she realized it was
real like how scared she got i've never
seen her that scared honestly i just
can't believe that none of the waiters
helped like that they did not give a
[ __ ] they did not care that i had a
dress
i had a customer choking and suffocating
like that once when i was a server and i
gave him the heimlich you did and did
you save his life i mean
i don't you got the food out you got the
food
you know what
he did tip me but i specifically
remember he left me kind of a shitty tip
oh he left me like
i was
i was like i saved your [ __ ] life and
you did every dollar you have you
belongs to me now i should have followed
him out in the parking lot she should
put the food back in his throat shoved
those [ __ ] tortilla strips right back
into his head
i was going to go out a good person
though because i tipped twice because i
didn't know how it works i tipped the
lady at the counter and then would you
give her
uh i think i gave her 15
okay yeah and then i gave the guy 15 as
well because okay i left a little bit of
a water mess water
okay
sorry for you
sorry for almost dying in your
restaurant yeah what do we do about it
yeah
right so so you stand up you're trying
to drink water you're spitting water
everywhere so how do you eventually did
you think you were going to die at any
point in that
i i got a little scared i just i gotta
yeah and then how did you get the steak
out of your throat eventually so
eventually it got to a point where it
was stuck
but there was air coming in okay so lena
just sits but we just sit back down
elena's like
like she grabs her i'm like you're gonna
try and eat right now let's get the [ __ ]
out of here i'm not i'm so embarrassed
i'm like well well no wait wait wait
you're sit back down but it's still in
your throat yeah but she didn't know
probably because like at that point i
could breathe but it was still stuck i
think she thought i got it down yeah and
then how did you get it down drinking
water or something we drove home
it's still in your throat still in my
throat on the way home i'm like beating
my chest and putting my like mouth open
like that i go home and like fish it out
and i swear i thought it was a whole
chicken leg i was like did i eat how did
you fish it out
uh with the toothbrush
you put a toothbrush down your throat
and took it out of your mouth
i no i did it to make myself gag you
puked yeah
but i had to like aggressively yeah
it looked like a full like four ounce
steak but that's what i'm saying you
took too big of a bite bro
it felt like they had expanded him or
something in my throat like there's no
way i i don't think that's how it works
but you know what this is the second
time in my life when i've choked and no
one [ __ ] helped me the other time was
in high school well i gotta say you
should have learned your lesson by now
bro
i'm not sure they should save you
what olivia he's swallowing like a snake
yes man have you ever seen the white
right yeah yeah lina did you see him
puke did you see the chunk he swallowed
no i was stuck in the car at the time oh
and i accidentally locked lean in the
car
because we went in the car and i went
same thing there was water lena brought
me water to the car and i tried to drink
that and it felt like i was drowning
again projected literally on the
windshield and on her side of the car
passenger seat so i told her i'm sorry i
have to get him back because your seat's
destroyed so she's in the back we get
home and i run out of the car and the
child lock is on for whatever reason
can't get out she can't get out so i'm
inside i'm like is lena cleaning her car
right now while i'm [ __ ] dying
and then she came in like 10 minutes
later she goes you locked him in the car
wait how'd you get out lina
i just jumped to the front seat oh you
had to climb over yeah but i i tried
getting out at first i wasn't sure if it
was a child lock or if it was locked but
anyways then i got inside and he was
like what took you so long
did you know he was still choking at the
time or you had no idea
i figured he would be and i wanted to
help so i was trying to rush but
i couldn't get out bro you're a mess bro
i could barely speak all day my throat
was so sore holy [ __ ] dude but real real
quick in high school when i choked the
security guard guard is like are you
choking i'm like yeah he goes you're
choking he asked me three times and i'm
like yeah yeah
then he goes okay follow me takes me up
three floors i don't know why the [ __ ]
the nurses
whatever office on the third floor and
then the nurse tells me to sit down and
just watch me until it came down
that's great man good times
lina i suggest you learn the heimlich
i'm going to she looked it up
immediately
because this guy's a
high-risk joker
yep
i've seen several people uh donate
saying that there's such a thing as a
swallow study test that uh
can um apparently help you if you're
choking
often like that i don't know anything
interesting i've never heard of those
yeah i got it
i think i bet you've studied that
anyway um
listen ab i'm glad you're alive thank
you
but uh let's let's get on top of our
life okay okay
yes sir we don't want you dying out
there
leaving lena a widow they've they've
dubbed you uh choker brain
ah
that's good i love that
that's good chad that's a good one well
there you go a b is surviving sizzler
ladies and gentlemen
sizzler
overall bad experience how did the steak
taste
we still have the steak in our fridge
actually you brought that [ __ ] to go
while you were choking on it i'm too
afraid to try to eat it oh yeah wait did
you did you say yo i needed to go boss
while you were choking on stick
lena did
oh my god well the waiter offered i
didn't i just said we're gonna go and
he's like do you want some boxes i said
sure lena's like want to go i have water
all over me
who packed did the go box the waiter are
you lena i did yeah lina goes
you want
[Laughter]
this is incredible story actually
sizzler ladies and gentlemen somebody
said sizzler did better than honda
oh okay
i saw a lot of people commenting that
because i tweeted that i almost died it
says learn people are commenting
a guy survives a boxing match with
kratos only to die from a time of stake
at the sizzler
sizzler in the next creator clash right
there it is
thank you a.b
[Music]
absolutely
all right um so if we're moving on we
should we have three ads so we should
probably do those and then um
we have that vip call we will almost be
ready for the vip okay so let me thank
our ads today
and then we'll move on to our vip call
which you guys are going to miss but
first let me think
the wonderful honey
today's episode sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer
i love honey i save money it's so easy
bro it's so easy it's a plug-in you do
two clicks it's on your phone and now
it's like you could have it on your
iphone but it could be on any browser i
think you don't have to think about it
dude
and it just automatically looks for
coupons at checkout
and these are all real savings that
we've got this is a g fuel saving that
must have been you love
yep that was me yo that's a like 30
what the heck
wait was it love or camp yeah that was
me oh
did you
i thought it was scripted so i just
agreed oh
my bad no these are all real love
love yeah
stolen valor what cam which code did you
use when you got g-fuel i know that's a
big deal
uh i don't know which code yeah they
just used whatever the honey auto
filling was oh but no like for don't you
get to use a code to support your
favorite gamer oh i just i just but he
got it from honey so it just randomly
assigned him one yeah oh you use one of
the gamer codes for a discount yeah oh i
see yeah well it says the code is
regiment so i don't know who's that
shout out team regiment yeah regiment
all right
uh dude i'm telling you man this [ __ ]
rules it's free money i mean i literally
use it on every computer
and ela is a chronic shopper and we just
save so much money manual searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past it's
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo what goes to the
place the best one that finds that cart
to your cart
shop it online
you click checkout honey button appears
and all you have to do is click apply
coupon wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site and bob is your [ __ ] uncle
honey finds a good working coupon code
you watch that price drop magically
yeah so honey doesn't just work on
desktop now it works on your iphone
dude i have this really bad cut on my
the sole of my foot
oh my god and i just like barely touched
it on the bottom of the chair and it was
just excruciating pain
ah
taking me back to sizzler man do you
want a band-aid no it's not like that
it's like my foot is so
dry and crap i don't know why it gets
like this oh you gotta get a petty i do
gotta get petty dude but it's cracked
down it's not a cut but it there's a
massive crack that goes all the way down
you got chapped feet dude you need you
need the nipple cream bro
what's a foot mask what do you got there
no this is the nipple cream for
breastfeeding mothers oh the nipple
cream it's like healing
magic you know what you should do you
should go online and use honey and see
if you can find a discount code on one
ah on some sort of uh cream yeah
cream what are you trying to bring it
back yeah i'm not going down
i'm dedicated to this foot tangent
um listen honey doesn't just work on
desktops it works on your iphone too
just activate on safari
on your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you're missing
out
on savings and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
the show
i never recommend something i don't use
and i do use and i love honey so get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3 that's jointly.com h3
thank you does someone want to look at
this
i just want to show somebody how [ __ ]
crazy this is take a look at this
oh maybe you can show it on the phone
oh yeah i had that but look at that look
at look how deep it is that's exactly
what i had it's so painful you want to
see something gross sure this is what a
foot mask does
that skin
your foot doesn't look that bad because
i use the mask but i had that
yo can you get a shot of this here
ethan if you put vaseline on your foot
in a sock and we've got nipple cream
yeah it'll do the same thing yeah i'm
gonna put some nipple cream on this [ __ ]
it's so good
wash hands thoroughly soften a pea sized
amount between fingers and apply to the
entire nipple area
after each field
yeah so i'm going to
here let me show you i want this going
to bring his phone over he has it on
this phone well as we're as we're
setting that up let's go to liquid iv
oh yeah
love myself some liquid iv
yes sir
let's do the foot thing first yes sir
love me some liquid iv here check this
out you really want to show the audience
this why not who's the [ __ ]
well yeah but you see how deep that goes
there
you see how [ __ ] up that is it goes
like all the way down to like
[Music]
so it's just i can barely walk right now
it's so [ __ ] painful they are the
worst it's the absolute worst happened
to me once before and it took a long
time to heal i think the first time i
got it taken care of i had to get a it's
crazy was it called manicure is that for
food pedicure
you could you could you want to watch me
put the nipple cream on it
no it doesn't stop my feet don't smell
you [ __ ] animal
take that back you tell them you tell
them right now that you're lying so i
when my foot was like that
hold on hold on hold on damn my foot
doesn't smell does it
are you serious you're muted
[Music]
amy did you smoke nice come back we come
here and smell myself i smell them feet
no that's [ __ ] i just i refuse that
my feet smell they might be [ __ ] up
and cracked and dry go ahead get in
there
smells good thank you [ __ ] you dan you
hate her ass [ __ ] i don't know what to
say
maybe
i'm just saying bro my feet don't smell
all right
and i refute that
okay i like this nipple cream on it
though it goes in there nicely
let her sit there let her do her work so
when my foot was like that my nieces
used to make fun of me for having a
crusty foot yeah i used to scare them
with it like you better go to bed or i'm
gonna
why is our feet like that i don't
understand theodore sees it and he goes
daddy why is your feet like that
yeah i don't know buddy it can be from
wearing sandals all the time i want to
talk about the feet how does it what
sandals make my like that i don't think
i i hardly wear sandals and i had it too
i mean i'm sure it can be but i do wear
sandals all the time do you walk around
barefoot at all ethan no
i mean at home all would just wear socks
but it might be that you're pushing
putting too much like pressure on the
back of your foot instead of the front
so you might need some kind of a
tiptoe thing
yeah
orthopedic shoe roll of a lifetime
okay it could be you could be overly
washing it
no i bare i i don't i treat my feet with
i love my feet
i'm the wikifeed man and dan they don't
stink shame on you for lying i just got
a little whiff or something i don't know
what to say come back here and smell my
feet then no again you need to equip me
of that [ __ ] bro i just it's not cool to
put that out there
you want me to pull open the saw yeah i
mean that's how it looks go ahead
oh wow dan's committed
well thank you dad
thank you you know what dan
thanks bro dan really got in there so i
appreciate that
thanks dan
he's a good man
acquitted you hear that he's acquitted
he's acquitted shout out to uh dan
apologize apologize for putting that out
is that a keemstar dan shout out
a shout out to uh dan
what
that's not you is it he's a fan
it's some other damn dan
thank you to liquid iv everybody
yo i love liquid iv because sometimes as
someone who has gerd
acid reflux coffee is not always good
for
gerd
and a product like uh liquid iv is
awesome because not only is it great at
hydrazing they have energy boosting ones
with caffeine in it which is great in
the morning
they have high special hydration
formulas and they have um
what's the other one they've got they've
got the hydrating the mood the boost
energy energy
and all the kinds of different flavors
too
um
it's great for exercising
and all that kind of stuff
the hot summer months are here and we
need to be proactive about keeping our
bodies fueled and hydrated making
hydration a priority can help us feel
healthier in our everyday lives you know
what this stuff's real good for when i
was sick with kovid
you
lose your appetite you get super thirsty
and these hydration packs are perfect
for
replenishing your body when you're sick
or hungover
but
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water helps hydrate you twice as fast
than regular water alone plus liquid iv
products taste great and they've got 10
refreshing flavors like concord grape
lemon lime pina colada
and tropical
[ __ ] punch
sounds like summer doesn't it
yeah so it's awesome man and it comes in
this little pack
it's got to be more eco-friendly than
like
the other brands that come in big old
plastic bottles
it's just a little pack you put in a
glass of white and you're good to go
[Music]
i like it in the morning man when i'm
not in the mood for coffee i get the the
the energy boost one it tastes great and
it helps hydrate you and gets me going
with a little caffeine
love that um listen the strawberry
flavor by the way if you want my opinion
is the best one so let's add
it has five essential vitamins
b3 b5 b6 b12 and
uh
before what was the name of that boy
band before before yeah yeah and before
four
and vitamin c it's got three times the
electrolytes as traditional sports drink
is made with premium ingredients non-gmo
free of gluten dairy and soy
come on you guys
24 million servings globally grab your
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or
you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use the code h3 at checkout that's
25 off anything you order when you
shop for better hydration today using
the promo code h3 at liquidity.com
or no just liquidive.com code
h3 you get that right then
sure did thanks
there you have it guys okay all right we
love it
and finally i'm not so good at getting
through these fast
anymore well we took a 10 minute
it's the version
anyways listen there's nothing to joke
about when it comes to stamps
[Music]
the post office is a waste of [ __ ]
time and let me tell you covet is
everywhere you want to stand in line
with a bunch of peasants and [ __ ] uh
pieces of [ __ ] at the post office
that's not pretty similar post off i'm
just saying in general people are stinky
and have coveted
so if you're running a small business
every second counts you can't afford to
waste a single moment
so why would you go to the post office
when you could be using sams.com instead
sams.com comics mailing and shipping
quick easy and effective
uh we talk about this a lot but dan's
girlfriend uses stamps.com every single
day she does yeah to run her small
business and i
sounds like a dream it is a dream it's a
dream come true
no trips to the post office she just
puts uh the packages together she's got
the little scale right there next to a
computer weighs it prints out the
postage slap it on the thing pick it up
they pick it up
no but that was a joke like 10 10 15 20
years ago if a service like that people
would kill for
you have it now today we're living in
the future man
you know with the james webb they're
trying to look like seven billion years
back no
that's too far now it's the perfect time
to live yeah when stamps start coming
why are always looking backwards time to
look forward look now
it saves time and money okay get this
you save money too discounts you can't
find anywhere else like 30 off usps and
86 percent off ups what
so it's time to streamline your shipping
process all you need is a computer
a printer no special supplies or
equipment and you're up and running in
minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you'll
want to send it plus stamps.com
seamlessly works with shopify amazon
etsy ebay and more and whether you're in
an office sending invoices or etsy shop
sending your products or warehouse
shipping orders
samps.com is your mailing and shipping
solution so stop wasting time start
saving money when you use sams.com to
mail and ship sign up with promo code h3
for a special offer that includes a four
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitment or
contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter the code h3
thank you thank you to our
friends over at stamps.com all right
oh
oh oh oh
interesting uh super chat just came
through
yeah what does it say mark donated five
dollars said this was a free super chat
so have a wendy's biggie bag on youtube
wait how do you get a free yeah what you
just gave me five bucks for free how'd
you get that youtube money are they
implementing i know um you know wendy's
biggie bag amazon does that uh
twitch prime sub where they kind of give
you a free subscription that you can
give to somebody but i feel like i would
have heard if they were doing something
yeah i would love if they did something
like that
you know
mark if uh
if you're still around let us know uh
how you got that free super chat there
what do we do about it yeah what do we
do about it
do you guys remember how howie posted a
prolapse anus on tick tock over the
weekend that was
i'll never forget
over this happened
big recollection of that
so is our caller ready dan our vip
caller
uh
they are they are you want to
set it up a little bit so um as you guys
know
there's been a lot going on politically
in the world not just in the united
states but in europe and england
specifically
their prime minister boris johnson
was forced to resign in what was a
shocking
turn of events
um boris johnson the people called him
like the trump-like english president
or prime minister
he has had scandal after scandal
and basically people have lost
confidence in him to the point where
people in his cabinet just started
resigning in mass
lots and lots of outs
but today we have what could only be
considered the forefront
expert in british politics
uh mikey
so mikey welcome to the show
so what what exactly is your credentials
to speak on on uh such high level
politics
[Laughter]
[Music]
right interview well that is interesting
that's that is i hadn't considered that
angle yeah so mikey um
so what do you make of boris johnson i
know the first thing that happened was
partygate he was caught partying during
covid
lockdown and and that got him a lot of
flack do you think that was justified
[Music]
i think it's a little far i think that's
an interesting insight for sure i'm not
sure i agree totally but i i i'm with
him
i'm with him fully actually you co-sign
that i'll co-sign that i understand it's
controversial but
i i mean
that's surprising coming from you dan to
be honest i know i
typically attack the other direction but
on this one you know well you know
initially the government denied parties
took place
he lied about it and then he had to
later admit he didn't realize it was a
party i mean you really gonna let him
get away with that one mikey no that's
not your id
you know it wasn't a party you buy that
mikey
[Music]
right
wait really
that's what he said
no
well there's been a huge actually his
party um
took a huge string of losses in the last
two months in elections which has really
lost his party's confidence
what do you did does that shock you
mikey that they took such losses in
being such a popular
dominant character in english politics
[Music]
no i didn't consider that um perspective
actually yeah well that is interesting
um damn okay
yeah so there was a vote of no
confidence in boris's leadership
and he basically said that he was going
to resign
and or actually he said he would not
resign
and the final straw came when chris
pincher as you know
had all these terrible allegations of
essay yeah
against uh other men and government or
like uh you know
assistance stuff like that
uh did you what did you think about
chris pincher did you know about those
allegations before
paste wow
oh
right right right right i didn't know
that oh
yeah that's crazy
wow
i can't believe i should resign sooner
than i can't believe you lied about it
yeah
yeah but the race is heating up now for
a replacement prime minister and the
tories are starting to get
uh properly chuffed
so what are your thoughts on the uh
conservative party are they doomed or
you know
are they gonna pull through what do you
think about the fate of english politics
that's i hope not
i i hope he's wrong
yeah i mean i think he might be right
i'm not sure about that one mikey well
listen mikey uh
without your political insight we would
be truly lost
um but i thank you for calling
and uh
you know
really really a unique voice in this
space so i thank you very much mikey and
people can find you on tick tock uh
what's his what's your tick tock handle
[Laughter]
right
all right
so you guys can find him there i'll put
that in the description
i'll put what he just said in the
description thanks buddy you're the best
okay
we'll we'll catch you next time when
something big happens all right mikey
thanks buddy we appreciate you mark guy
really really educated yeah
what is his actually tick-tock though
mikey with two eyes ka8 yeah we'll put
that in the screen i do want to plug the
guy we love mikey
such a guy
yeah people say mikey would be a good
co-host for for frenemies for frenemies
i was thinking leftovers i think we
should get a third mic you hassan and
mikey
um he just he really has this incredible
i haven't heard a political mind like
that since gnome chumps ski practice
right
well they just
you know all the pundits online and and
in the main in the lame stream media
they just go round and round and they
never really just cut to the core of the
issue like mikey's able to so
appreciate him chris said i had a free
five dollar super chat too says one time
offer is personalized and time limited
let's go what the frick okay you guys
all got five dollar
uh super chats let's let's get it give
him up yeah come on who else are you
gonna give it to
ludwig
elwig yeah
[ __ ] got him
youtube already paid him a bunch of
money to switch i'm just here for the
love of the game
we should leave so that we can then come
back with one of those youtube uh yeah
youtube does good [ __ ] about me bro they
used to now they don't give a [ __ ] what
do we do about it
i think i i got in too much
trouble
and then they said [ __ ] this ethan guy
he's an idiot
well wow that was awesome thank you so
much to mikey
i guess let's do this ace fest um
actually we have a lot of stuff we we
kind of glossed over here we got some
new james webb photos
let's take a look
so is this all of them for now
we got them all eh yeah
yeah nothing looks dumb i don't ever saw
like a real close-up
so do we have before and afters
uh not for each of these but uh i can
give you something because these are all
basically reshoots
of old hubble photos
but man the details on this is pretty
nuts dude this is like a huge nebulous
gas
and uh
it's like 30 300 light years across or
something
just so you know too
i'm not going to point it out because i
don't want to get us in trouble with
youtube but we did hide the prolapse
anus somewhere in that image that you're
looking at right now
no you didn't yeah we did
it well i'm gonna keep looking until i
find it what are we gonna do about it
what are we doing no it's not what do we
do about it somewhere in there
uh i don't think the james webb is more
powerful enough yet to see up that
that level of detail
beautiful though huh
when my friend neil bent over this
happened
check the discord real quick
check the discord they says
okay this this is actually really
interesting
this is uh what do we do about they call
this god's eye but it's actually god's
prolapse
this is one of the new james webb photos
really really incredible stuff actually
do you see the bottom detail super
beautiful
learn facts about kova 19
what are we gonna do about it
[Music]
here this has the before and afters so
here is um
here is
let's see
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do with
this
here is that was a before and after that
was before and after that you just
scroll back but no the hubble one wasn't
black and white it's not black and white
well those these are these are all false
color anyways so it may have just been
so colored as vibrantly but this is the
same photo this isn't hubble
okay well i didn't i don't know which
one's hubble then
this isn't the before and after
i guess i'm wrong that's the same i
don't know what that is
you know what i'm saying
maybe this okay here this is the hubble
the hubble's such junk bro that thing
[ __ ] sucks look how [ __ ] it is
look at this dog [ __ ]
lame dial up internet crisp 4k baby
lame awesome
sucks
rules
uh hubble was a loser james webb [ __ ]
yep yes sir you know after we talked
about it on monday a uh
a fan of the show
uh emailed me
um
about
the james webb um who is a nasa employee
i had to do it oh what the [ __ ] i did a
triple take did you have a nasty email
yes they did at nasa.gov so what did he
say they were just giving some they were
saying they watched the show and wanted
to share some more info um i actually
asked uh
i replied to them a little before the
show and said that's so cool and um
if you ever want to call in
talk about it because i guess they work
on it um
let me know so that's so cool i don't
know if he's gonna have more insight
than mikey but i guess yeah
yeah they uh
the one insight that they gave was you
were asking about all of those what
seemed to be lens flares the bright
spots uh in that original image you
remember like it looks like the big
yeah it's got crosstalk stars or
whatever they're just stars right yeah
ethan was asking what the big boy bright
star was in the imagery any of the stars
in those deep field images that have
those lines on them they're actually
stars within our own milky way galaxy
these stars kind of get in the way of
the shot photo bombing the thousands of
galaxies behind them
those star lines are actually
diffraction spikes they're caused by the
supporting veins holding up the
secondary mirrors so it's not the star
doing that but each individual telescope
based on how it's built we'll have a
different kind of diffraction spike
you'll notice that the hubble images
have diffraction spikes with only four
lines whereas the web has six because
there's six uh that's awesome yeah i i
learned a bit about that so if you want
to know if a photo is from the hubble or
the web
hubble has four
lines and web has six so there you have
that that was pretty cool
but um well that's awesome uh wow people
at nasa are listening to the h3 podcast
ladies and gentlemen oh and hopefully
he's taking that edison survey too
i sent a link that has a slider
comparing the two images
you know what's crazy is like
you think that the universe there's so
much empty space
apparently you know these these photos
they're looking at are so small parts of
the night sky they say it's like a grain
of sand at arm's length i mean you can
imagine how small that is
and you can't even get a photo of these
[ __ ] without like five stars being in
the way i mean is it it doesn't feel
that empty when we look through this
telescope
there is a lot of stuff out there
a lot of stuff
but it's all so far away so far
away
doesn't anybody stay in one place
anymore
the hubble telescope sucks my [ __ ]
dick
james webb rules i kind of like this old
hubble one i'm not gonna lie you should
check out the link i sent it's pretty
good when using the slider to compare
how crappy the old one was compared the
new ones so here's this one
the gods prolapse and then here it is
and
yeah there's a lot more detail going on
there but let's pull up this link that
av what do we do about it what do we do
about god's pro-life
sorry oh damn
damn well somebody is saying that
there's a new phillyd thumbnail and that
you're in it so what the future did i do
now ace fest probably we'll pull it up i
gotta know uh it's not showing on his
channel it still shows yesterday's as
the most recent what the [ __ ]
oh one minute ago sure enough
yeah show me i want to know
well he keeps auto playing god damn it
all right so here we go let's see
um this is the video you're talking
about [ __ ] is this picture
what the [ __ ] phil really why are you
doing this [ __ ] to me bro yeah
where did you even find that photo dude
like that's not even a photo you had to
like go fish out some really
unflattering photo of me from some
podcast
seriously dude
you know philly do you use me in the
thumbnail so much she probably just has
there's a whole floor dedicated to just
digging up unflattering photos of me and
has a folder in it
so what did i do this time
uh
i i found it
i saw you talking about texas
texas oh my tweet yeah oh my god love
that for you philly what did i say about
the punisher thing
wait what tweet
i said if the punisher was real he'd be
[ __ ] hunting down those cops
okay i just lost it right
it's at the very end of the video
you gotta pull it up i gotta say yeah so
what this there's
footage came out about the uvalde police
that we all knew were cowards oh let's
go
he even god needs an attorney eh
let's go
go
yeah the evaldi police were like [ __ ]
around in the hallway
like [ __ ] 30 of them with tactical
gear and uh
shields one of them liter and i [ __ ] you
not you know we were debating work shots
going off in the school why were they
over there not only were shots going off
while they were in the hallway
kids were screaming for their life
one of the cops casually went over to
the
hand sanitizer and gave himself a squirt
that [ __ ] is so crazy
yeah okay i saw a possible
not to run interference for the cops
because obviously they [ __ ] up royally
and [ __ ] them but i did see a
plausible explanation for that which is
that that wasn't that was um the medic
and he was getting ready yeah he had a
gun i thought well
he's the person who was going to be
doing triage and therefore was do they
know that i'm just saying i saw a
possibility
i'm just saying
we're going to watch the video we can
determine if they're medic or not reach
lux over there
you're not so different from reach looks
um and then another one was checking his
phone
uh
while waiting yeah the phone guy with
the punisher logo and he had a punisher
screensaver i i got no explanation for
that other than [ __ ] that guy
and i said bro if punisher was real he'd
be hunting you down [ __ ] or maybe i put
it another way you're a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] cops are [ __ ] the
police bro [ __ ]
the police let's let's defund yuvali
police let's start there we can all
agree on that
burn that whole [ __ ] police station
to the ground bro
and that sheriff is like getting pissed
at the media for releasing the footage
corrupt fat [ __ ] of a loser
[ __ ]
god
so upsetting
burn what down the cob station i
wouldn't say that
why are you what abe said you said burn
it down
well
if you you want me to correct the record
on something
it's rewind time
no [ __ ] that you know what i'm saying
burn it all down the institution
you know
so upsetting man
here's what i said i'll just read it to
you
you know
i said uh
let's get it started
time stamped and
oh philly deep showed my tweet
yeah
okay then discord okay legend
we take it back we love philly
that's a great photo
let's see
it's not a great photo he goes i'm
trying to make a serious point and he's
using me looking like an absolute goon
it's disrespectful
i expect better philly philly defranco
i've called him skinny legend so many
times he could owe me abuse a better
photo than that
have long been asking for we have to
bear witness to history and transparency
and unrelenting reporting as a way to
bring change but one thing many people
on both sides of this issue do seem to
have in common is outrage towards the
police response but you've got the likes
of podcaster ethan klein criticizing the
officer who appears to check his phone
saying he did that while the gunfire
went off to the cries of children very
badass another person saying a fist oh
he cut out the
the best part
he cut out the part that was a little
more inflammatory yeah look at this
[ __ ] he's checking his phone
with the punisher logo [ __ ] you're not
a badass you're a coward
you're a bunch of [ __ ] also cops
aren't supposed to identify with
punisher he's a violent vigilante
murderer the fact that you see yourself
as punisher is not good don't you
understand that
like you're not a superhero bro in fact
you're just like a little [ __ ] boy
coward
i said if the punisher was real he'd
hunt down all these [ __ ] for
letting kids die
love that they think of themselves as
some badass symbol of justice though
all this guy did was casually check his
phone while gunfire went off
to the cries of children very badass
looks like he's about to shoot his own
foot too like what's that what's that
what's going on here
anyway
yeah there's a lot of really depressing
things coming out about uvalde man
it's so heart-wrenching there was this
interview with this
kid oh [ __ ] dude
you call me it's so sad i don't know
but i think it's important
that we don't just let this story go
away
let's just [ __ ] do it year old son
jayden hid under a table in room 112. me
and my friend were scared and we didn't
want to talk or nothing and
we covered our ears
so we won't hear the gunshots
you covered your ears
were you hearing a lot of gunshots
me and my friend didn't have a lot of
space so we just tried not to move so he
won't see us
and
were you wondering what was going on why
you had to be there for so long yes
what were you thinking
i was thinking what was going on
and i wanted to see if i didn't want to
uh the guy the gunman see me
seven weeks after the attack parents in
yvaldi are still begging for clear
answers
they want to know why police waited in
the hallway outside the classroom while
their children were terrorized for more
than an hour by the gunman he's like mom
i heard him outside mom they were
yelling and
telling the shooter to
come out
he was talking and laughing to himself
walking around
and whenever he heard
i don't know what little girl was called
out
officer like when officer called out
she's like i'm in here
he went over and shot her
so the police were close enough to the
door
where
your kids could hear them yes
and the girl answers back
we're in here
yes
and then he
kills her yeah
and the police never go in there were
still lives
i could have been more saved they would
just gotten there faster and just gone
in
like
you wear a badge
you have a gun they shouldn't be scared
when they got there they were still
outside waiting for a little bit
and
i was telling my friend i was whispering
to my friend that was falling asleep
is there anyone in particular you missed
my my cousin rahelian my best friend
chase
they died
miss them
what kinds of things would you guys do
together jesus when we would have reset
we would always play together and play
hide and seek our tag
you feel comfortable talking about what
happened and
is it helping you
yeah
i feel a little bit happy because my
friends are in a bet my friend and my
cousin are in a better place
in a better place where don't happen
nothing really to say about that eh
nothing really don't add to that
except that like
i don't think it's okay to just like
forget that this just happened
year old son jaden hit him
it's so [ __ ] up dude
on both sides i mean the shooting itself
is [ __ ] up by itself
and then the cop these punisher this guy
looking at his phone pretending like his
punisher
i mean the irony is insane
he's outside checking his punisher
desktop on his phone
while kids are being he's standing there
for an hour
well babies are being murdered i i'm
what the [ __ ] bro
punisher screensaver
i'm saying [ __ ] the police the whole
institutional policing is [ __ ] bro
yo this dude any cop that has a punisher
screen saver should be [ __ ]
reprimanded period
it's like brain cancer
these guys are unaccountable for
anything and guess what's happening to
the uvalde police department nothing
guess what's happening on the gun
control front
i guess something's happened actually
there was a bill passed but it's not
very good
here's the guy who's all the police
department is they're getting
investigated by the feds right well so
far nothing's happened and the mayor and
the
mayor and the police chiefs have the
balls to get mad at the media
right yeah all the people are lockstep
that are local or whatever but i'm
pretty sure
i i i more likely nothing happens than
not so by the way does this possibly a
medicare doing the hand sanitizer he
doesn't actually have a gun i don't know
again i just saw people offering that as
an explanation he doesn't appear to be
armed he's on a uniform so
that kind of made sense to me but
who knows i mean
i mean it just shows how casually they
were there on the hallway
in the video
this hallway goes straight up to the
classroom up here three cops initially
chased the gunman and when he shot back
at them they came running back down the
hallway like a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm just like well i guess they're
that's that and they they [ __ ]
freaking bolted three cops
ran for their lives and
chill here for an hour and i love that
they try to act like oh we thought
everyone in there was dead and it was a
a
barricade situation he was still
shooting that he was still shooting i
mean you heard one of these women say
who was there the cops were asking
people to tell where they are and then
the gunman would go and [ __ ] kill
them and they say that they thought it
was a barricade situation
that cop literally got this person
killed like if he he literally he
he
he directly is the is the cause of that
murder
this poor little [ __ ] girl who's just
asking for help dude
at his request i mean how
[ __ ]
is that dude
hell no
dude kids should never have to
experience terror like that that is
unforgivable
[ __ ] these people bro
[ __ ] these people it's crazy too this
video they released it says um
the crap the screams of children was
edited out to
yeah that's a pretty disturbing
disclaimer to see in the corner yeah too
i i whatever they edited out the screams
of children
this is the screen sitter he had
punisher x blue lives matter
which i actually even recognize because
i i know a cop that has had that on his
car before
oh yeah they love that with the blue
line or whatever
from the
it looked like maybe his was the
american flag version of it but whatever
you know it's the same
it's the same point being made
regardless embarrassing man
uh it's just
somebody said imagine being the editor
for that footage yeah
sympathy to whoever that was i had to
go through all that
yeah in this video i retweeted only 3000
likes from a couple days ago like people
just don't want to watch this and i get
it it's very painful and difficult to
watch but
you know what
the nra and the police benefit are the
only ones that benefit from us not
talking about this
it's just [ __ ]
it's just that was heartbreaking yeah it
is it's it is it it tears you up man
yeah that uh
that was gut wrenching dude
it's like the interviewer was pressing a
little hard
on that kid you did
i mean
it was a little weird i felt like
kept like did anyone you know passed
away i understand maybe asking once but
it's like he was going a little too much
i mean i agree yeah i think the
interview was powerful no i think it's
powerful but
i mean maybe keep it more for the
parents
i have to keep digging at the kid
well this kid just
knows this kid just saw he saw his
friends die bro i know ask him once
don't ask me like [ __ ] i think they
should release the pictures of these
dead [ __ ] kids in that classroom so
people could do see what that their m
their [ __ ] ars are doing to people
we they benefit by us whitewashing this
and pretending like nothing [ __ ]
happens
like what's this kid supposed to to
suffer in silence like and not talk
about the fact that his two of his best
[ __ ] friends died as he hid under the
table as this guy just
you know what i mean like you gotta see
the bitter truth of it yeah no i can't
[ __ ] why wash this [ __ ] anymore
release let's see what it looks like a
classroom full of slaughtered [ __ ]
kids so that these people can actually
see what their weapons are doing
it's easy to pretend like it didn't
happen
look at this police cars with the
punisher logo on the front like uh dude
this is pathological you
this this disqualifies you from being a
police officer do you understand that
it's ugly
it just looks bad it's ugly dude but
what does it say about their intention
about what they're doing who they are
they see themselves as some tactical
badass some vigilante who doles out
violent justice that's what the punisher
is that's not what the police are
supposed to [ __ ] be
the blue lives matter means our lives
are more important than everyone else's
that's what the [ __ ] that means bro and
that's why those cops didn't save those
[ __ ] kids because their lives were
more important than those kids
police chief howards this is from
kentucky the police chief said uh the
decal represents that we will take any
means necessary to keep our community
safe right
yeah that's not what it means yeah
dumbass [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] losers
cowards
blue lives matter
those poor kids i mean jesus christ
yeah let's see the photos man let's see
what that classroom looked like
mm-hmm
those are what those kids saw if you
think those questions are harsh
you should see that classroom
yeah just saying i agree with you on
that i mean if the parents are okay with
it that's what happened with you know
emmett till it was until his mother
showed the photos that there really
started to be some backlash
um well we need to arm teachers to be
honest
that's what we need
we need to arm teachers y'all
we need to [ __ ] arm
them teachers
even though 30 cops couldn't
you see what's fun you know what's funny
they go
he was heavily armed to the point where
30 cops were scared to engage in so do
you really think that people should have
this gun
and if 30 cops
can't
stop
this guy then how's the [ __ ] teacher
with the handgun gonna stop him
it's insane dude i i think you you're
absolutely right ethan they were just
trying to protect themselves they
weren't doing their job they were called
that's what blue lives matter i mean
[ __ ] cowardly i mean they're trained
not to put their their nothing you know
and the fact that those kids lives got
lost it's it's over
and they were just [ __ ] standing
there like [ __ ] cowards
honestly i'm afraid uh to have kids and
having to go to public schools i'm
afraid for my nieces and even in school
it's scary dude's so scary dude yeah
can't imagine being a parent
now
ah dude so that's what's going on out
there guys i mean this is just you know
it's hard to watch but it's important we
see what's out there that's all i'm
saying
well there you have it uh uvalde ladies
and gentlemen
if only those teachers had guns
the idea of that doesn't make sense like
you just want random people wandering
the hallways with guns and then the
police come in they don't know who's the
[ __ ] shooter it just turns into a
good old western shootout at the school
makes no sense
people j there's actually
like a large number of elected officials
senators
leading republicans that are saying we
need to arm teachers
that's so [ __ ] dumb it makes no sense
it makes
it's like obviously a bad faith argument
the fact that these people can retain
their jobs after saying something so
materially and provable [ __ ] dumb
and and intentionally obtuse they should
not keep their jobs for that [ __ ] bro
they're pro dead kids ted cruz goes we
need more good guys with guns how many
good guys would continue there's 30 of
them waiting in the [ __ ] hallway
you know if teachers had were armed the
cops would go in and shoot them
they would go in and kill them because
they were just random people with guns
they don't even know who the shooter is
or what they look like
they're going to [ __ ] kill them it's
going to be a
chaos
ace fest ladies and gentlemen
to change topics
whiplash
yeah i mean listen it's a it's a mood
killer but i'm just [ __ ] so sick of
it we can't forget it
uh
you know um ace fest
still getting [ __ ]
but as you know
it was awesome
yep
ace fest ruled
but it's not stopping them from catching
[ __ ] like look at this
the insider wrote an article about what
a flop it was and
it's just kind of crazy to see
that they're spinning their own reality
that everyone went there with
preconceived like all the t-channels and
drama channels and now insider it's like
what about our experience
karissa chang
that's the author fans who said they
attended the ace festival are sharing
photos of collapsed tents
crazy expensive food and huge cues and
blistering heat i don't think any of
that's true
actually
look the collapsed tent was one thing
that happened due to high wind
crazy expensive food i don't think you
guys had the experience no no they're
all like good prices very reasonable
yeah
i mean it was normal food truck food
which
yeah i mean it didn't feel particularly
inflated
so crazy expensive and huge cues in
blistering here i don't think there was
any lines
or well the only lime was for the meet
and greet for all the fans to um to meet
him yeah
so how do you guys feel about that fake
news headline as uh mainstream media
once again look at this photo it's like
it wasn't like this was it
no we were flying high on that thing
yeah that was the one that we there was
almost died on yeah
but yeah i'm curious how they got this
photo like i said i feel like all the
commentary channels went as early as
possible ran to the ferris wheel or ran
to whatever it was get a good angle take
photos like this well if you look
through this article they
source they they like link
uh embedded some tweets and streams and
they're they're all from you know the
people the comments these channels well
it's not it's not really fans but i mean
i guess they might have not realized
that they just figured they were oh they
know over there
like a t channel basically at this point
we were somehow left out though i don't
know that's what i'm saying bro
why were we left out
yeah but this photo shows literally
three people
like it must've been in the morning when
they were just setting it up
yeah maybe early in the day it
definitely was
like from the videos we saw people
streaming while they were there
significantly emptier
first thing in the day than when we got
there we got there like 3 30 or
something like that
you know it was really close it was
popping by then okay maybe not yeah
there's a bunch of people oh on the ride
yeah let's write them oh yeah you're
right there's if you look closely
there's only um you're right
it says here they they source from spill
sesh which says h family festival was a
mess
get um free rides you get
great parking
free parking they got them on the
freeport parking they're not wrong they
got them big time on that one we did say
free parking
10
you guys the next thing is that the
website originally when the tickets went
on sale promised a lot they said access
to yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you got a
point there we're not just like oh hi
they seemed really engaged and really
took the time to create everyone and
gets a lot of criticism for how they act
on camera they really like put it on
and like put on a show and it doesn't
seem very natural and they did seem that
way with their fans they seemed exactly
how they are in their videos with their
carnival wasn't worth it and most people
paying really just wanted to meet
themselves
that's a good reporting
but then what do they say ace family
took place on july 9th according to
spill search like why what the [ __ ] kind
of sourcing is that
controversial influencer ace family
hosted a festival july 9th attendees
shared reviews on social media saying
they thought it was underwhelming ace
families austin mcgroom said the event
was a success
he seems a little [ __ ] up of an
article if i'm being honest and i'm out
here defending the ace family okay
somebody in all caps in our chat once
again said they did say food would be
free and took it out later i don't
remember you where are the receipts
people keep saying that i haven't seen
anything
send it to you
if you got anywhere if you got the
receipt send them we'll call them out on
yeah
free food is insane yeah i uh i have to
be honest i think i i heard that once
too somewhere you got it
i need receipts yeah we stop we will
happily acknowledge that and call them
out on it if if somebody can provide
some evidence but
uh a lot of people keep saying that and
i i have not seen
the free food has been kind of an insane
offer
yeah that's not that's very i've been
looking for it too but i can't find it
but i've heard it somewhere but i i
can't really you got mandela for sure
yeah maybe maybe by the way thank you
nick clark for five gifted cells
appreciate it
out of their youtube video really
you can do that but i still think that
somebody would have saved it we would
have we would have commented yeah some
dude come on you can't get [ __ ] past
people these days even if you clip it
out this should be very interesting
anyway let's see um
they said they experienced long lines
overpriced flute and bliss during heat
the couple
blah blah blah
disneyland meets coachella that was a
bit much
tickets were 300 bucks for three people
500 for five
um
121 dollars at the door
for context a one day pass to disney
starts at 104.
pretty awesome is that true hold on i'm
pretty sure disney is more expensive me
and lena went to disney nice by six oh
what i thought it was like 200 bucks for
a disney ticket
yo if insider got disney tickets wrong
then they that's
i think it depends on the day you go too
oh what the [ __ ] wait hold on wait
follow that through though if you keep
going
okay standard theme park ticket yeah
click one to five day tick oh i see i
see
yeah disney's nuts how they like
it's like planning a flight now
let's see okay
one adult
how many you got to do one day at top
you have it on three days i think i do
oh
twice three days the same why is four
days cheaper oh per day
right
and that's just for the one park too
that's not california adventure in
okay well let's just do disney let's
just keep it a fair comparison
one park per day
park hopper we don't need none of that
one park per day okay choose your dates
yo they changed the price per dates now
okay well ace fest was on saturday so
we're talking about a weekend event
so this saturday is 164 bucks
do i have to keep going disneyland
disneyland
what do we do about it
disneyland is [ __ ] insane dude what
the hell
what's genie's service it's like it's
the fastpass oh cause you gotta get that
and that's like 60 bucks you you should
do that for free
charging people
[ __ ] the mickey mouse [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] them
such [ __ ]
oh we got to get the genie because
otherwise you're just screwed waiting in
line yeah
and then well you got to get parking
right mm-hmm
i mean
okay
no before you go 200 bucks let's go
215 bucks in the house
and you want to talk overpriced food
disneyland's completely overpriced oh my
god but and again it's you can't compare
because people are going because they're
fans of austin and catherine it's like
it's a meet and greet you know obviously
disneyland's more great but there's also
a hell of a lot more people there yeah
and like you said lunch is super
expensive
disneyland's a whole thing the fried
chicken there is worth every penny
though
yeah this dance good fried chicken
we ate there when we went um we did yeah
when did we go like two years ago
something like that before covered 20
you got to do that again it's i mean
that [ __ ] is worth everybody in my
opinion
yeah my money yeah
yeah
oh i'm saying i'm saying i've been to
disneyland i feel like since uh we went
last and it's just worth it
you're talking about the disney ticket
or the vip ticket
no i'm talking about getting in the park
just to eat the fried chicken oh the 200
for the for the just for the pleasure of
eating their chicken yes yes i respect
that
i feel like it won't truly feel magical
until i go with you ethan
right you guys win and it was
wasn't the same because yeah we get this
celebrity
[Music]
it doesn't you know 600 or however much
i pay it doesn't feel too magical
no it doesn't you know how much it costs
for the vip i'll tell you off the show
yeah i want to feel like
i'm on a magic carpet with you you know
it does feel really amazing when you go
and get that
i went no lines and [ __ ] it's crazy that
is truly the happiest place on earth
when it's that way i mean we rode every
ride in both parks in one day that's
pretty nuts
go ahead zach
oh i think cam was cam that was cutting
it oh because i had
what you got cam i think my camera's
still [ __ ] up so just bunny me i guess
it's nice freeze frame oh no we're just
gonna stay on this freeze frame of you
okay yeah
go back again go back to the old school
here i went uh oh i'm [ __ ] up again
but i went with my buddy lyle and alec
and uh we went from the moment the park
opened to the moment the park closed
from like 8 a.m to 12 p.m and that's how
you get your money's worth is going to
fall for sure yeah it's true
if you've got it's it's very exhausting
your feet feel like they're going to
explode but
it's actually should disneyland's pretty
fire i'm not even going to lie like they
have crazy shows at night dude
it was awesome our grades are crazy we
had a fast pass and we still didn't even
hit i think i think we probably got half
of the rides and we went all day we had
the fast pass that's kind of [ __ ] up
and started charging for fast pass
because you're screwed if you don't get
that it's not yeah it's not even a
normal fast pass either it's not like
you get to skip the line it's like you
will you go to a separate line but you
have to like plan it like an hour ahead
and two hours two hours ahead and you
can only go like one ride at a time and
then you have a cool down time
right so it's kind of like a sucker pass
i mean it's still yeah one of my fondest
memories of us going to disneyland is
the first ride we did was that uh ferris
wheel the one that swings disney one
yeah together we did that yeah and i'm
like i'm not doing this man i'm not
doing this man you're like you're
[ __ ] doing this zack and i'm
screaming for my life yeah it's cause
this thing is just
i love that ride it's just so [ __ ] up
we couldn't get zach on the swings at
the ace fest i don't do rides smart man
i mean it sound a little sketchy disney
i trust not this you know
how dare you you know an awesome broom
so they say for context disney tickets
at the door cost 121.
okay whatever i'll compare to disney or
no it says 104.
i don't even think that's true anywhere
on any day what a [ __ ] liar dude the
family has been embroiled in several
controversies over the past few years
which has affected the reputation most
recently
creditors foreclosed on their 10 million
dollar mansion
they since moved to a new luxury home
oh you remember that one they did not
immediately respond to insider for
comment what are they supposed to say
you know what i mean
so oh yeah this is what i saw it wind
blew over the tent one drama youtuber
filmed a large tent that appeared to
collapse during the festival
i was watching that one shout out a
toesie
oh that's the
oh
oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
oh
maybe we got the clip
hopefully the audio is decent oh they
didn't even turn
upside down amateur hour you didn't even
timestamp an hour 40 stream insider
idiots oh
he also said it was empty and was
disappointed
another uh youtuber 1.2 million
subscribers
uh was also there apparently so much for
free food i don't think they ever said
that
it's so it's something let me check if
anybody's dm me anything
also there was multiple food trucks it
made it seem like this was the only menu
anyway they said so much than anybody
just saying i don't think it's coming
buddy
i just want to make it clear i'm i'm
willing to
be wrong about this if somebody's got
the
got the time stamp
some evidence of that
the food trucks that were bomb
there is an interesting dm i got which
is
a little off topic
someone says
oaksie said i went back on the way back
machine april 11th no free food
mentioned
on the
well other people were saying it was in
a video that they clipped out though so
i don't know if you would well i guess
the wayback machine does have videos on
it too doesn't it i think it's a mandela
effect guys
what were we gonna say dan sorry to cut
you off um
i i didn't see this message that
somebody sent until now about the whole
punisher thing apparently there's so
much association with the you know
right-wing lunatics with the punisher
skull logo yeah but a few months ago
marvel redesigned it
that's his shape i like the old one
better well it that
old skull is gone apparently this is his
new logo i saw that um there was even a
recent comic where punisher is like
the police shouldn't be using this
because i'm a vigilante you guys aren't
you're supposed to serve him he murders
cops yeah he kills everybody right
yeah it's a little goofy that they all
actually what's his name avery our our
wonderful mod posted uh
a frame from a punisher where he's like
why are you [ __ ] wearing this a cop
was wearing the punisher logo he's like
take that off [ __ ]
is that awesome what a loving liberal
yes so he says so much for free food i
gotta say these are not that expensive
prices
five dollars for a corny what they
really do i mean three dollar churro
that's what's up that's a bop right yeah
bottled water three bucks i mean
it's not that bad
just saying
just saying
now if you go to dodgers stadium they
charge like ten dollars for a water
bottle now that you can complain about
that's robbery that is very true i mean
those [ __ ] are out for blood
and 18 for a [ __ ] can of beer too
yeah that i mean that
that's like them spitting in your face
and saying what are you gonna do about
it yep
but this these are fine prices in any
way free food
so here we are defending the ace family
um
that's what we do
this this this pretend journalism is so
[ __ ] up though it's like if you're
gonna go and write an article and try to
be like a serious journalist
you can't show this [ __ ] about free food
and not say
there was no evidence of that like of
offering free food i mean this is just
this is just
why are you pretending to be a
journalist
it's embarrassing to youtube ecosystem
it hurts us that this is
the level of journalism being done on
youtube it's it's embarrassing so
embarrassing
stan ace family forever
[Laughter]
as a twitter user said post a picture
of a menu including a ten dollar cotton
candy and a jumbo corn dog for nine
bucks and a water for three i mean yeah
you identified
the three most expensive things on the
menu
all these free super chats are still
coming through by the way are they
really yeah these five dollars youtube's
running like a promo or something what
the heck guys
let's get this going
i mean there's been a lot of money
glitch
money free money honeydew
let's go free super chat thanks daddy
google tyler
let's go tyler aldrich
love that
shout out to susan
yo if they actually do that free sub
thing like um
like twitch emma's yeah like twitch does
i don't know why they haven't done that
no good make it part of youtube premium
if you get youtube premium you don't
want to pay
i agree though people could be signing
up for that [ __ ] like a gang
yeah i personally use
why are you leaving comments uh ab i'm
testing it maybe
i was just looking at a chat baby goes
test
remember for 24 months though shout out
a b
wow two years that's right
i'm not seeing the like
the like free option though
well yeah people a lot of people are
saying i don't see it those are the
see all these people that are dumping
theirs right now these are like you get
one free super chat
per month if you're a member yeah but
that doesn't actually give a donation
there's a lot of people that are giving
these five dollar
super chats they're not members it seems
like some people do not have it yeah
here i see another one it must be like a
split a b test thing
yeah youtube does super many a b tests
so every time they implement a new
feature they give it to some people so
that's probably our
art
you get members are going crazy right
now you get one with a gifted sub
wait what that's what somebody else do
about it
if you get gifted a sub you get a free
five dollar donation i'll try it
that's a money glitch wait can you give
subs on mobile
that is a money glitch we got to make a
deal with our saudi prince yeah where
what's the new saudi king's name
um muhammad bin salman yeah maybe uh
king solomon is a fan let's not talk
about making money all right tai lopez
who wants to lose some money today who
wants me to take their money
i hope he's not a loser i hope he's not
a fan because then i would fear for this
uh
insider reporter that we're talking
about their life is in danger he's gonna
invite you over to the embassy forever
um
let's see according to ace family
website rides and games
were included
free
however the price of food is not
mentioned on the site okay you say it
you mentioned it
just saying
this is apparently videos and photos
show
huge lines to meet them
this was going viral is some dad was
talking mad [ __ ] in spanish
i saw a funny translation here maybe i
can find it
he was there with his daughter he didn't
know who they were yeah he clearly just
got dragged along he was like and they
don't even have alcohol this is [ __ ]
they uh
various other drama commentary youtubers
said they attended the event
and got sunburned well no [ __ ] you're
going to lancaster and i mean that's
kind of your fault yeah
a lot of when we played our video a lot
of people were like oh dan's bald head
is going to get scorched or whatever no
we let we lathered up baby sunshine
hello
i didn't get burned i got a nice little
crispy tan you got a little crispy a
little crispy skin yeah we got screened
up my guy we got screened up
watching parents pour water on their
kids to keep them cool while austin and
catherine chill in the shade
i found a little bit of an interesting
clip about the free food oh okay we got
something i'm here for it i'm drunk
solid i'll drop them
[Applause]
all right so in the discord okay
okay okay this is really interesting
there's nothing 100 it's still just us
saying it but you'll see basically i
just kind of want to go on the road okay
okay all right all right we got
rides and stuff right the free rides
and free food too right and a meet and
greet with the with austin and i'm kind
of hoping to get that zach mentions free
food yeah oh i think it's a mandela
effect that's just
joker
i was hoping yeah and i know right no i
get it so i see
yeah i mean our audience might be
remembering that but thinking
it was from the ace family but it was
actually zach mistakenly said well let
me ask you zack you said free food no no
no i remem i i
zags on the side i think yeah i would
have said that
because i i read it and they said in
their video if i'm not mistaken chet's
saying that i corrected zack shortly
after oh oh you did i mean i i don't
know but that's what i've seen in chat
listen if someone said free food there'd
be a clip i'm just saying
in this day and age
come on
same in a sea of slander and lies
so i gifted some memberships i'm still
not seeing a free super chat so yeah i
think it's just wait i think it's the
recipient that's a free oh okay so
whoever i gifted can you see if that's
what they said how many gifts and subs
you just buy maybe
well i went to do this experiment i
thought i could just buy one i didn't
realize i have to do five so i gifted
five you bought five you just paid me
like 25 bucks
what's up player
this is a good deal my employees pay me
you pay me well thanks so i'll i'll
reimburse you
i'll send you 25 on uh give you a
sizzler gift card yeah
keep it
that's actually a great
birthday should go to sizzler sometime
maybe if we do disney trip we should hit
up sizzler dude is there one in anaheim
let's go i haven't been to a sizzler
since i was like 12 years old i [ __ ]
love sizzler dude really yeah yeah man
i'm in i mean i have some great ass
memories it's literally that steak
looked good i'm not gonna lie nice grill
marks nice and juicy their hibachi
chickens good their malibu chickens good
they got great soft serve it's good time
there you have it good diet coke
you know oh yeah yeah yeah you know some
places aren't as good as others that's
true i should have took a picture of
what i pulled out of my throat that's
where i messed up
that thing was i would have loved to see
something even howie mandel wouldn't
what do we do about it
all right another five dollar one from
alec man yeah these are really good
i didn't get a gifted sub but i can send
this yeah i don't think it has anything
to do with the gifted subs i think it's
just that might have just been a
coincidence they're just testing it out
yeah
there's no such thing as a coincidence
um let's see uh subsequent insta blah
blah blah blah
they said
this now this was funny i saw spill sash
tweet this i love this this was kind of
interesting
um
it's like a heidi klum an american
bikini ride what what the [ __ ] is this
did you guys see that
yeah i mean some of the rides had that
on there yeah i saw some people having
like a little moral panic about this
it's like really dude she's wearing a
bathing suit it's a woman in a bathing
suit like what how how big of broods are
we like have you never been to the beach
this is hilarious to me because in my
hometown we have an arab festival an
islamic festival and i've seen stuff
like this on the rides and i've never
heard anyone comment on it ever
what goes down at the arab festival oh
man they got shut down man a bunch of
racist ass people came with like pig
heads and [ __ ] what yeah they gotta shut
down wait wait racist people came with
what like pig heads people were
protesting yeah just whoa
that's gnarly yeah yeah they ruined it
we don't do anymore used to be an annual
thing
oh that's sad and it sucks because the
community that it's in the part of town
that it's in is like you know not a lot
of money is there um lower income
families and it was like
it was like a big deal in summer time to
go to that festival for summer and they
got it shut down
what though [ __ ]
you want to guess those people were
magga
oh for sure they still drive around
i was watching a documentary that hassan
reacted to about my hometown and they
were driving by the mosque with like a
big trump
uh flag and like beeping the horn and
stuff and
i was saying that what's so [ __ ] up is
they're probably driving in front of a
funeral right now
based on what i was looking at like it
was a funeral yeah terrific i love that
that the the arabs and muslims are the
problem these guys are showing up to a
peaceful
[ __ ] event with pig heads
yeah or carnival sick [ __ ] dude those
are the atheists walk around with
punisher
those guys who lick the boots of cops
[ __ ] pathetic losers freaking weirdos
horrible bro you're [ __ ] weirdo bro
so but what do you guys do at the
festival before you guys got terrorized
by white supremacists nothing we had
like uh
you know you could try like fresh food
and just normal festival carnival runs
yeah carnival ride well so it wasn't so
basic painting it's a normal carnival
like halal food yeah i love food and
like
shirts i say like bolo instead of polo
or bubsy instead of pepsi
all goofs and gaffs
sounds like a good last time
this that saudi prince gave 50 gifted
subs
thank you uh
uh
the king of uh saudi arabia
loved that oil money
finally coming back to me a little bit
um
back to ace fest
let's see
the owner of drama count spill sess
shared a tweet on july 9 which she said
was taken at the festival show two
attractions that each depicted a woman
wearing a bikini did you really need to
include that i mean what the [ __ ]
bro it was advertised as a family event
i thought ace fest is for kids
isn't this a family event shut up see
some titties idiots hell yeah
that was the ride olivia ian and i were
all spinning on
the heidi klum on it
yeah were you able to control your clue
your overwhelming desire seeing a
painting of
heidi klum in a bikini i didn't even pay
attention to it oh [ __ ] you know
damn i think they just did two sets of
50.
just dropped 100 yeah our saudi prince
oh my god thank you so much legend
truly generous
ace family posted screenshots of
positive reviews
um
okay
this article's too long guys
we got the idea
this is pretty funny
there's no one else bro what how did
they even get this photo you know they
kicked everyone else off for this photo
up
they probably shot that the day before
oh that's set up night you know what
cause they made they we watched that
video where they were there where he was
like suck a fat donut or whatever and
they were there at night
although they are wearing the same
clothes you guys can yeah they were in
all the way
okay oh maybe not maybe it was just that
evening
yeah i don't know it's just you know
what there's so much to hate on them for
legitimately it just feels like such a
reach at this point
what do we do about it
um that that that that doesn't it
doesn't serve anybody to be
to be doing this kind of stuff so there
you have it ace fest forever ace family
forever
austin and uh catherine are invited to
my
uh
either already they're already
circumcised okay yeah i was thinking
that's already done
sorry to all the foreskin activists out
there
listening
people get angry now when you say you
search andrew andrew yang is typing up a
angry letter yeah he's anti-circumcision
yeah i get it but listen it's frankly i
kind of am too i'm not gonna get my kids
circumcised
i get it i think it's just weird i
forget that
when i was a kid you didn't even think
about it yeah and now
like to be honest i didn't even know
that penises were different than mine
until i was like a teenager yeah same
mm-hmm isn't that weird it was just kind
of the default here in america the first
time i saw it i was like what the [ __ ]
is that what's wrong with that guy's
dick
it got deformed
that's so i mean yeah that that's pretty
[ __ ] weird but
i personally am comfortable circumcising
my kids and um
i'm not mad that i was circumcised or
anything like that
i'm not mad about it but it's just like
given the option it's like yeah why
would it i mean it's a cultural and
religious issue yeah and i'm not
religious and
are muslims i don't care about them so
like to say to outlaw it is basically
i i don't know people try to compare it
to like clitoral
circumcision and it's really just not
the same thing
in my opinion
but delete me from this conversation
i couldn't ask for your opinion
are you going to circumcise your kids
baby yeah
there you have it
rather than you know just have it done
with from the beginning and i have to
deal with it when they're older oh no no
no no no
actually it's pretty incredible when you
so now they do it in the hospital like
the same day they're born or the next
day and that [ __ ] heals so fast when
they're babies
it's like back to normal in a couple
days it's pretty nuts interesting
because it has like
wolverine regenerative powers which is
why they do it and collect them and give
them to uh who was the celebrities
yeah
it is pretty incredible it's not that
it's not as crazy and bad as it sounds
as a baby as an adult i'm sure it's
traumatic it's
[ __ ]
um
yes sure
that's the ace fest there was actually
some other interesting updates so deaf
noodles as you guys know
confronted the mcbrooms asked them how
to scam
and
so there was like a press conference for
his boxing match correct and death
noodles tried to attend he got kicked
out
and apparently they tried to
take him out on the lake if you know
what i'm saying
i do hear what listen you know what
you're saying this is kind of
interesting
audio audio it didn't let me yet
even though i ended up getting a pass
then on the end uh there was a whole
thing that happened also they like
kicked me but then here's what happened
that was interesting
when austin eventually left first off he
had a security guard like walk up to me
and ask me what question i was gonna ask
and then
he
like walked out with five security
guards or something and
he like invited me into his van i was
like awesome can i ask a question he's
like yeah come in the van asked me the
question in the van i was like uh what
no i'm not getting in your van bro
uh and his security guards had a big
smile on their face they were all like
get in the hand
kenneth man because it's very creepy
so
uh yeah that's it it ended up with a
stalemate of austin inviting me into his
van me saying no
somebody else tried to get in then they
didn't let him so they but they wanted
me in the van so i don't understand what
the hell is going on anymore
i know what was going on they they
wanted to uh have a couple words you
know what i'm saying one against the
family come in the van i got a couple
things i want to tell you
you come to me on my fight presser
on this beautiful holy day
come take a trip in my van i got a
couple words i'd like to talk to you
you ever been down by the lake
death noodles
i would like to ask you a few questions
step into my van
i'm not asking
it's not a request death noodles
come in the van we'll have a little ride
i got some dire cokes and ice in this
limousine
come have a nice refreshing drink in my
van
i got a beautiful lake house let's go
take a trip
death noodles
hey death noodles turn off tracking on
your phone let's take a trip i know it
was you freedom
do people know where you are right now
deaf noodles
let's take a ride i'll give you a ride
home talk about things a little bit
[Music]
all right guys come on now yeah i
already got the nunes
pretty
[Music]
i think they're just [ __ ] with him
obviously right i think he should have
gotten the van
i mean you got you got it have you seen
it yet
yeah you got to see the whole clip okay
interesting it's it is
it's weird
def went to austin's press conference so
wait we have a clip of it interesting
so apparently death noodles went once
got kicked out and then came back with
this disguise
no he went in initially with this
disguise oh he got kicked out wearing
this and then he got a press pass from
adam sala
you know it's interesting he probably
would have got in fine if he didn't wear
this
he just drove so much attention to
himself and obviously like that he's
there to cause
cause a ruckus
but we have
a clip of death trying to get
this is interesting
this is from deaf noodles
okay let's see ace fest controversy
continues
i was immediately greeted in a very
friendly way by the legend himself
blue face but shortly after that our
luck changed
how you doing bro
is that who he's fighting blue face
why is blue face there isn't he a rapper
or something or blue face is competing
in the event
he's just chilling there at the entrance
uh the person downstairs
guys i'm sorry oh you gotta call the
cops on us
remember folks this event was advertised
as free and open to the public and they
told people to pull up
guess they just didn't want us there
i don't think anybody came bluefish just
said hi to us i don't think he cares but
i think it's okay to come outside though
all right just wait don't mind waiting
right out here right out here is okay
well i appreciate it buddy thank you so
much
okay all right well i guess wait let me
i guess we're gonna get something i was
dead wrong because shortly after that
they said 5-0 after us and had us
escorted out of the building promptly
through a
back stairway we got kicked out
they're they're acting like we're
[ __ ] terrorists you got kicked out
too
yeah i was right there behind you guys i
was like oh [ __ ] but who's that he's got
his ace family scarf on
uh
another t-shirt sure we watch this right
before the show but he's been with dev
since the beginning of the video okay
they care that much about you
they were acting like we were [ __ ]
terrorists like we're about to blow up
the spot they're like scared of us
they're scared of us anyway i made do
with what i had and just started talking
to people as they made their way out of
the building firstly with adam saylor so
yeah tell us about how did they like
kick this out they wouldn't let us film
so tell us how everything went in there
um it went great man it was a good press
conference july 30th it's gonna be dope
dope uh yeah yeah yeah yeah well who you
gonna watch it you can watch it yeah i
got tickets yeah i've been watching they
kicked you out man because they said we
didn't have press passes i'll press past
the field man
oh [ __ ] really they might kick us out
again
that was really cool for the record
that's uh
that's def's co-host on his podcast the
gentleman that was with him oh okay yeah
so adam sayla is one of the main
fighters in this event right yeah that's
kind of dope he gave him his pass
he's a prankster
i remember he did some really [ __ ]
pranks though like on airplanes and
stuff kind of cringe stuff yep
yeah there's a whole kind of weird
funnel i don't know if you've noticed
this of like
arab can i say yeah youtube yeah every
middle eastern influencer is so [ __ ]
embarrassing besides myth that's the
only one oh myth yeah myth yeah
but like fousey and this guy are always
doing stuff and it and when i go to i
always wonder who's watching this and i
go to the comments there seems to be a
lot of uh
arab slash muslim
fans of theirs
yeah they do have a lot of fans i
shouldn't say all of them but i mean
majority of like the popular ones that
are like pranksters and stuff like him
and fousey
yeah they have a weird fan base but it's
uh
super cringe you should be the new
spokesman for
the arab muslim i'm i'm trying to do my
part yeah you should you should be there
when i spoke about islam on front of me
is i got eviscerated
but
there was also a lot of people who were
very nice and like it was nice to hear
someone talk about islam in such a
open-minded way and not scare me about
it they were they were mad you weren't
conservative enough yeah
which is funny because my dad's family
is super conservative
so crazy how y'all are just so much like
jews yeah but the tattoos and all that
[ __ ] like you're not supposed to do that
our penises i do feel like reformed
reformed judaism yeah the penises
the jews the pigs
i feel like reformed judaism do you feel
like reformed judaism has come
become more acceptable in america than
like reformed
muslimism
definitely like 9 11
islamophobia and stuff just off the
charts
because like nobody nobody's gonna be
like you're not a real jew if you have
tats like i don't think you'd ever get
that
i feel like
i feel like you get some but maybe not
as
maybe not the same degree that could be
wrong
my grandmother would say that
you're not really jewish if you have
tattoos yeah that's the old school yeah
that's the old school stuff my
grandfather am i sorry my grandmother
god rest her soul told me crazy just
you're going to hell oh the yeah the
demons are going to burn my tattoos off
and drag pull my arms out of the socket
and drag my soul through hell that's
awesome yeah i miss her so much i never
got that all i got was you couldn't be
buried in a jewish cemetery
yeah that's not actually true you can
really mm-hmm dude it's so crazy one
thing that is different about us ethan
that you point out to me is that you
guys don't believe in hell which is
crazy yeah because everything we do
we're told we're going to hell that's
why i think judaism is such a cool
religion in my opinion i mean obviously
there's conservatives who take it way
too far and are psycho [ __ ] freak
pieces of [ __ ]
um a lot of them in israel are like that
but
there is no hell which i think is so
cool people are
are not living and doing uh mitzvahs for
a ticket to heaven yeah that's hype as
[ __ ] and also they're not we're not
scared of internal damnation
yeah it is hype as [ __ ] i agree i wish
and they were the first ones the jews
had that they're like and then the you
know they had the christians and the and
that muslims had to come along and be
and talk about hell like that [ __ ]
wasn't there in the first place right
you know death to all jews you all had
to bring that [ __ ] in yeah hell is a
retcon actually
it's dlc
it's it's a dlc yeah
it's a payoff [ __ ] dlc you have to pay a
microtransaction to unlock no hell is a
bad dlc man
although hell and christianity is kind
of [ __ ] because like if you're a
christian hell's just for anyone who's
not a christian they're like
you know they're like yes i raped a
hundred kids but jesus is dope they're
like okay you're fine yeah
you know
it's crazy how they say muslims like you
know are so violent and everything
because
we like anything we do we're told we're
going to hell and uh
yeah even like like people who are
religious a lot of them will even say
even if you're a good person you go to
heaven
if you miss prayer you'll make up those
prayers in hell before you go to heaven
when you go through you're gonna be
doing some time before you make it
that's awesome
that's crazy
yeah there you go um anyway
let's get back to deaf noodles
where he gets confronted yeah
because i click the timestamp oh here
gives his press pass here is the van
scene that's what i'm after
all right austin can i ask you a
question
yeah yeah come on get in the van let's
go get in the van i can't get in there
get in the sprinter yeah
because i got places to go afterwards
wait it didn't actually seem it seemed
like they just didn't want to get
accosted out there
it was a gracious
uh invite for him to ask it's sick let
it roll for like two more seconds
i i
the initial it seems like it's just kind
of jokey or whatever okay keep watching
okay interesting can i also they were so
fast because he was like i don't even i
okay i'll watch interview him from the
outside let's go okay get your interview
get my interview get your [ __ ] van
let's go i'm not getting in your
interview
get in the van
[Music]
i'm not getting in your van right now
all right i'm not getting in your videos
all right
oh i appreciate it
that's just very weird to invite
somebody into your van like that
interview
let him in the van
let him in the van
that was weird
uh he should have gotten the van though
what are they gonna do to him i don't
know dude
do you think they would have roughed
them up dead noodles
you come take a trip in the van don't
worry it seemed jokey to me at first but
after like the fourth like get in the
[ __ ] van i was like
what's going on here yeah you want to
come into my car
yo i love that austin has like the same
security level as post malone
like big ass samoan dudes
it's like i i
you're just not that famous austin i
hate to tell you
you know what i mean
i still don't know how he affords all
this [ __ ]
security like that ain't cheap
especially ones that roll for you where
they're like get in the van you know
because if you just hire them for the
day they don't give a [ __ ] about it yeah
that drama
get down
so you think he should not have gotten
in the van
no definitely not
just i mean if he was like maybe live or
something
think they would have [ __ ] him up
[Music]
like it's maybe not [ __ ] him up
but i i don't i don't think the the
interview that they were offering was
going to necessarily happen i think it
would have been a a talk you know what
i'm saying i mean i think they
identified that he was the guy that
trolled them like the day before and
they were probably pissed about it and
i don't know i could definitely see them
like threatening him they're willing to
stay the [ __ ] away from us
right from the day before yeah i think
it would have gone something like this
it's just
in the van no problem
just the standard interview it would
have made him an awfully good refuse
get in the van yeah that was gonna be
his ransom video
i'm being held
just please
i need a hunt i need 10 000 subscribers
before they free me
i just don't know what they would have
done to him like if they really did some
[ __ ] they would have got busted i guess
they could have drove him out somewhere
remote and dropped his ass off
maybe it was carpool karaoke
james gordon was going to be in there oh
you missed it oh you're
or it could have been the the taxi cash
oh is the cash cash the cash cash yeah
or maybe
ben uh whatever the [ __ ] his name for a
hundred bucks what did howie mendel take
in july 2022
that promptly got him suspended was it a
a prolapsed anus
b
a man's penis
or c
a fleshlight and a dog a dog
a fleshlight in the dog nope that last
one was ethan the answer is
i only post that on instagram stories
right yes for the record there's been a
lot of
chatter about that in the church oh is
there has been well just people
i didn't see any comments or reactions
to it i was curious
about it
yeah some people demanding a uh
explanation for your instagram story i
just thought it was funny i thought you
guys might want to um
it's funny i just thought you guys might
like to see some of the interesting
stuff i found
it's not funny
um
yeah it's a dog there's actually dogs
with fleshlights in them which is so
[ __ ] crazy
they say it's for your dog to enjoy but
oh what that i thought it was just
that's a real thing no it's a real thing
they sell it as a no as a
i'll pull it up i don't know i guess i
believe you i should i not pull it off
no no no no no no no he says no no yeah
you don't show that we can't it's a dog
it's a little dog with like a fleshlight
entrance on the behind on on his butt
side and dude i thought that was just
like a photoshop joke i had no idea
that's a real [ __ ] product
so i was thinking that apparently you
buy it for your dog who's horny but
actually i think people use that and i'm
just going to be
i did not come on my dog i don't think
dogs know how to use fleshlights
wow it comes way worse knowing that that
was real oh yeah i did not put my dick
anyway i don't remember what i typed to
find it
i think it had to do with how we
the how we prolapse thing and then
somehow that yeah it's on my store if
you guys want to see it
is it still in there
yeah it's still there why it's not it's
not vulgar
really
what
it's super matte but it's so i don't
know
too fat of a dog [ __ ] for a dog to
stop
it
oh here here's the censored version
the price is like
what do we do about it
what are we gonna do about this dog
flashlight did you guys mention the
price
no i don't know 367 dollars
how did you find that
i found it
on aliexpress
it's expensive man how much is a normal
fleshlight well i guess it's more than a
normal fleshlight because you got the
yeah it's just a [ __ ] little stuffed
dog though
i mean i thought it was made by uh
here's a new one to light up the runway
guy yeah see that's what i thought i
thought it was
i thought it was a joke
sadly not
real i'm seeing them on amazon for like
a normal one for like 70 bucks
it's for the likes of shane dawson and
folks like that
jordan peterson might i've never done
anything weird with my dog exactly
i did not [ __ ] my dog
well
there's a product just for you now so
you don't have to [ __ ] your dog
um well there you have it so
wow what i mean what do you think would
happen if he got in the bus
i i said what i thought would happen
what
that they would just threaten him and
tell him to stop coming around not show
up again i don't think they would have
like actually and what were they gonna
break his camera because he was filming
maybe
yeah
could be wouldn't that be more
interesting
that'd be an awesome story
you're saying def [ __ ] up not getting
in the vlog yes you got to get in there
you got to get this i don't know
i wouldn't get in the van i think he
made the right call get in the van guppy
it's austin mcbroom what's he gonna do
the man [ __ ] a doggy fleshlight
he's not a sorry i don't know i'm still
reading the flashlight reviews on amazon
very interesting they have reviews
burrito
bonus valentine's gift from my
long-distance partner he tried to use it
once hated it and threw it in the bin
obviously cameron turned such a waste of
musty what wasted money
someone bought that for a human being
and wrote a review about it
they wasted their mushy bro
you're getting in my head man you're
giving me
putting i'll see you in everything
yeah they're wasting their musty
wait did they write that no it didn't i
don't know where the hell my brain works
because i was wondering if it was a joke
review or not no no so this one says
uh one star review knockoff brand don't
buy i bought a real flashlight before
and thought this was the same thing
uh but why are they not mentioning that
it's inside of a dog no no no this is
just reading a flashlight i'm just
reading freshly no i'm not reading the
word why are you reading fleshlight
reviews i mean dogs can't write review i
mean
he was looking up i was looking up with
the regular one because the other one
was so expensive what but what do i want
to read the fleshlight reviews i want
the everywhere
out of it
it's funny it's funny
okay read more fleshlight reviews
me and my friends used to do this for
fun back in the days but i don't think
it's i know some reviews i don't think
it's that crazy though she was stroking
herself out of the fleshlight
texture
and smell her off putting throat in the
bin
did anyone like the fleshlight yeah oh
you got a lot of that's the second
yo read me a good one maybe
what can i say five star it's pretty
good i was always curious about these
toys and just how to close
[Music]
of course but it's great for simply
getting off building and maintaining
stamina and it could be fun for you and
your partner very versatile discreet and
super easy to clean
okay there you go my seat is all over
this place that's disgusting
all right to close that
phase banks ruined it
face update the great luxury of coming
man it's a bummer and mom's basement
ended because we haven't gotten any
fresh phase banks memes in a while blank
that's why
rip to the goat i'm actually glad faze
banks realized associating with keemstar
was a major l move for him
because like they haven't done [ __ ]
together since that show ended which is
good for him
yeah it's true
ugh it's just maybe we should have uh
banks into that
triumvirate of uh
austin mike maljak and uh
and jeff trying to be your friend oh
yeah banks is kind of down to be besties
with me right
humor
he's always he's always done with that
h3h3 humor h3h3 humor
um listen if death noodles got in the
van what's the worst that could happen
you just do a podcast on the bottom of a
like you understand
let's do your interview out on the
bottom of the lake pretty good tie a
couple bricks to your legs
you can ask the fish what they think
about it davis
got beat
hey while you're down there you can say
hi to the other guy that asked me for an
interview
if you catch my drift
all right
thank you that killer fast before they
turn on me
let's see we got uh wendy williams did a
tmz interview
apparently she's just
i don't know she's
a successful one so my question about
when when did she become
like
senile or what are they they're saying
she has early uh onset
alzheimer's
dementia
and
my question is well
when did this start because
there's been a funny business going on
with her for decades
have you seen her show
i mean some of the the the weirdness
from the last year or so of her show
maybe you could attribute to that i
think you can definitely attribute the
weird way in which it wrapped up and
they didn't even have her attention yeah
the final episode uh did her podcast to
that it's so litty
but here's uh i think it's kind of sad
what's going on with her to be honest i
i am a fan i actually am i think she's
such a character
uh she added so much light
a texture to this show she really did
she's been a
she's been a staple for a while now but
that being said she did a tmz interview
let's let's take a look and we can gauge
for ourselves
so wendy williams uh has kind of bid
farewell to television um we know that
already but there is a plan she has
she has a big plan
it does not involve television it does
involve communication uh it involves
communication
wendy doing a show not a tv show
um and a very profitable one she
believes it will be so uh without
further ado let's bring in uh
the guest of honor to tell us all about
her plans wendy williams joining us on
tmz live once again wendy
she looks kind of like a [ __ ] mess
what's going on is her is it her hair
her hair is a little messy like her wig
is all crooked and [ __ ] isn't it
it's definitely not brushed out fully
yeah something's going on there thank
you lina
see you she got a fat wario necklace too
isn't it
yeah let's think it's probably for wendy
oh wendy right
welcome back hi wendy well
welcome to my formal apartment thank you
we are duly impressed
um
so look let's get right into it um
that's a big statement for somebody
who's been a fixture on television that
you just have no interest more than a
decade so tell us about a very
successful one so
morton ira talked
and i was like you know i've got enough
money to do something else and what i've
never done
podcast
which by the way
podcast everyone has but when you're
famous
podcast will make more money for me
being famous than doing the wendy
williams show what's going on with her
hand why is her hand on her like like
glued to her chin
she want to show off that i think she's
wrong yeah i think she's flexing the
bling because she refers to it a couple
of times oh my god
looks like she's i was thinking she was
covering a pimple with this finger
because it doesn't move her mannerism
yeah i wouldn't read too deep into that
her mannerisms have always been a little
quirky she does a ring reveal in this
video that like big one she wore it on
the wendy williams show all the time and
she like takes it off and she's like i'm
starting something new and it's a huge
diamond but it's it's not the same ring
okay so she's about that bling
yeah she's so she's iced out and she
wants you to know about it yeah okay
interesting
but she is displaying i think she's
overestimating how much she's gonna make
on uh her podcast
i
her show was pretty successful i just
don't know she's very famous watch
i will
i think i mean she has a big fan base i
think there is a chance that she would
make more money on a podcast now i don't
know about that she that's assuming yeah
i mean that it actually happens and that
it's a hit
you know but for some reason i just feel
like well the overhead on a podcast is
so much less than running like a studio
like her show
was
not a low budget show says her salary
was 10 million dollars a year i don't
know okay maybe she's not like that much
but on the wendy williams podcast i
didn't realize she was making that much
yeah the show is popular
yeah i know it's i know it's popular but
yeah 10 million is
10 million a year if you want my opinion
when these traditional
media people generally come over and try
to make podcasts like this i'd be
surprised if she's even gonna pull a
hundred thousand views i'm just being
honest
well
normally i would agree with you however
i believe before she ever had a tv show
she was a a radio star and so and
podcast it's really not that different
than like you know talk radio which is
what she has experience in so it's not
that she's not won't be good at it it's
that when you're on the radio or on the
tv people watch it because you're there
because you're on the tv and they're on
the tv yeah on youtube on a podcast
people have to go seek you out and
that's not easy that's hard people think
because it's free and accessible and
everyone has the internet it's easy it's
actually harder
for people to watch your [ __ ] on the
internet you'll have to go find it she
doesn't know the game a fair point
that's a fair point yep click bait
thumbnails all that
i'm going down i'm wishing her the best
though i'm there i need more fart sound
bites and oops and hops and
that's all of us i you know just saying
podcast where will i go i'm not sure
europe
you know the france
wherever i want to go
also i know
us
i know
you know
many people
many people
dr oz by the way you know dr oz of
course yeah
all right my friend i've been in new
jersey jersey so many times i can't
count
also you know
i know
plenty of people
so
i'm ready to
like
fortunately i have enough money i could
do nothing at all and just relax in my
gorgeous apartment
by the way
doesn't look gorgeous
oh do you not really it looks good
i feel like to add on to what you're
saying ethan i feel like she's waiting
for the sound cues or like the audience
to laugh
yeah and that's why there's like the
awkward
nothing as she looks around
dude that was a pretty wild what is all
this about dr oz in new jersey and
france it was pretty wild yeah it's the
the coherency is not
uh what's the thing that's not wrong
she's like i know dr oz so it's all good
for me i think she was like i think
if i'm trying to interpret it is that
she was trying to like say that she
could
get big guests like dr oz doctor i was a
big guest he's currently running for
senate so
okay well do we have any senate
candidates willing to come on anyone can
run for senate
well he won the primary i guess i should
say he's not just running personally
okay
i hope he [ __ ] eats [ __ ] though by
the way dr oz such a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
that guy and whatever [ __ ] doctor i was
going to talk about him we'll talk about
the beautiful
wonderful wendy williams that's right
he's sitting on my throne
from the window is that your throne you
have there
excuse me
oh now we can see it well all right so
glad to see you took that with you so i
i want to say something it's interesting
to me because i used to do radio before
i did tv i did radio and i loved radio
in fact i think it was my favorite
medium
that's not that dissimilar from
podcasting and those are your roots too
thank you thank you by the way this
right here
this was on the wendy williams show
no longer
many money
okay
any money
what's happening
i don't know it's not what people are
saying yeah she's clearly sad she's not
he's not doing that well i saw her
brother doing an interview where he was
like we were trying to get her not to do
this and she did it no
yeah everybody kind of knows just saying
people saying she seems to be on drugs
i don't know if it's drugs no maybe i i
think she i think there's something more
going on yeah there's something i don't
think it's extraordinary drugs yeah
chad's saying her eyes she has graves
disease that's her eyes bulge like that
yeah her always her eyes have always
been kind of like that well they seem
particularly uh bulgy on this afternoon
i mean
she has a very mild case compared to
what i've seen it could be very bad
mild that's mild yeah oh graves diseases
how much worse does it get really bad
i'll show you yeah let me see these let
me see this [ __ ] dude
peace and love to all of my graves
people up there
graves gang
grace
grave gang
i got [ __ ] crazy guys so shout out
wendy william i got tested for graves
because your eyes are so massive yeah no
i don't have it though i just have big
ass that's crazy
crazy eyes just stand just the standard
case yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah that's oh [ __ ] bro what the
[ __ ]
that's that's intense man oh man is
there a treatment for that to fix that
it's it's uh
there is but it's often not worth the
risk because it could be dangerous
it involves
if i'm not mistaken if i recall
correctly it involves cutting your
eyelid
at a certain point and bringing it down
which only like helps hide it doesn't
pop your eyes back in there yeah it
doesn't pop your eyes back is this is
this just a genetic thing it's related
to thyroids so you can in some cases uh
so you can get a
radioiodine therapy yeah my eyes hurt
looking at that
so you could treat the thyroid and then
the eyes kind of chill out in some cases
yeah
dude that's that's all
man whoa
shout out to my graves people out there
bruh
it ain't easy
[ __ ]
shout out to uh oh i'm on my way to
support wendy williams 50 gifted subs i
have a feeling that was our saudi it is
the saudi prince our saudi benefactor
just saying and thank goodness
because she she needs some help seems
like
she's i'm done with this
goodbye that's the old that's the old
it's the old wendy williams show we're
not on that anymore right
okay i'm no longer on the wendy blue
show
bow out gracefully you know morton ira i
love them but guess what this is also
huge diamonds what the [ __ ] bro
damn
whoa wendy out here flexing on the
haters though bro
she might be losing it but she got that
she got ice and she looking good bro
look at that size of that thing
so many years i can't count yeah it will
salary right there how
that's like a 10 million dollar diamond
it looks like yeah and that thing's
never seen a diamond that big in real
life
will jeweler gave me all this
all of this
when do you like a wrench this is pretty
entertaining though i'm not even gonna
lie like this is still pretty fire gets
crazier it does oh my god
all right at around six minutes she six
minutes she uh she shows her feet and
that's pretty that's important should i
go six minutes is that what you're
talking about olivia like a little
before there maybe so let's go to five
minutes and see what's the feeds part is
gnarliest yeah we get to see her feet
yeah oh is she on wikifeed are those
picks on wiki feet already could someone
check
i think i would bring down the website
we'll check
um what what else are you gonna be
bringing to the the podcast obviously oh
yeah you know lots of stuff hold up oh
damn they were fast on that
whoa that's pretty flexible whoa
oh my
you have to watch she she has let's just
watch let's let's we're skipping ahead
here looks like a potato bro
there's a reason
all right let's go celebrities that you
can bring on as guests but what do you
want what does wendy want to do in this
show that's going to be different from
your from your tv show well
you guys i mean
maybe sneakers you know i've been on hsn
and qvc
correct
[Music]
okay maybe i'll do something with that
or something else you know i have
lymphedema you know what that is correct
i know
okay you don't know lymphedema
all right i'll show you okay
sure okay
lymphedema is this do you see this right
here look
okay
no look closely right look please
hold up i can't person higher behind you
yeah
yeah
okay do you see this yeah
all right it's up and down
okay
wow okay yeah that is i can only feel
maybe five percent of my feet wow do you
understand right
well this is gnarly they asked
what's your podcast going to be like and
then she pulled out her foot
yeah 85 it could be i mean i guess it's
a good thing that she doesn't feel it
because it can be very painful but it's
a buildup of fluid in her lymph nodes
yeah
wait how does that end up in her foot if
it's lymph nodes i'm sorry not lymph
nodes in her lymph system
normally i would be in a wheelchair
i'm not in a wheelchair
i stand up how are you feeling wendy i
know we saw some video of you out in new
york city uh last night and you seem to
be
moving well i mean how are you feeling
um just physically you got that supreme
drip
that's though
better than you
better than you
that's no doubt [ __ ] wait there's no
doubt
i'm shocked so you're able is there more
to watch or is it um
that's like that was
the part that that's sad well shout out
wendy i hope that uh
you know
i don't know just to clarify because i
have a standing um reputation in the
medical community i just fact checked um
it could be in a certain part of your
arms or legs but it's most commonly
caused by damage to your lymph nodes or
vessels as a part of cancer treatment
well shout out wendy i hope everything
works out and i for one will watch that
podcast mentally sound or not i'm in i
think it's gonna be great either way and
i don't know if that's like
a bad thing to say but she's
entertaining with or without her uh
sanity
and what could one could debate if she
ever had it to begin with i mean how can
you lose something that you never
which we love
huge wendy williams stands in the office
yeah love love
the insane big fans of the insane here
or as trump would say i love the poorly
educated
i love them
what else we got here we got we watched
jordan
uh we have to talk about
mike and jeff
what's in the title oh yeah let's talk
about that we still have cam man vs
machine but we're probably already
running out of time
for that
aren't we
we've been going
two hours 40 minutes
yo this story is kind of nuts bmw
is rolling out dl [ __ ] seas for their
car
they're making all their new cars with
heated seats built in and you have to
pay them 18 bucks a month
to activate the heated seats what a
nightmare
what a [ __ ] nightmare what are your
thoughts on that i mean jesus christ
let's not do that please
yeah no anti-consumer bro that's [ __ ]
up well
dan did some uh
took a deeper dive into this and there
is a rationale behind it
so
and i'm just stating i'm just stating
this
objectively so don't jump down my throat
people because
it is still pretty [ __ ] up but that
they're saving costs by making all the
bmws right so right now why do they got
to charge
monthly
well so think about this right now i
mean you just recently got a car right
and when you get a car
there's options
for like all these bells and whistles
but i don't think the options is the
problem is the monthly payment that's
the problem
right but here's the thing
right now because there are different
like
versions of the car with different
options
on the production side
they think that they can save money
by basically
streamlining their production making one
version of the car that has all of these
options and then
when you sell the car
all of the options you can pay for
individually as subscriptions also you
can get a lifetime
subscription which basically is
like adding the option
would normally be when you go to buy the
car dude the monthly [ __ ] well it says
here it says the options is 18 a month
or a yearly subscription for 80 bucks
three years for 300 or pay for unlimited
access to your heated seats so that's
for 400 that's kind of what i'm
wondering is like was it 400 to add the
heated seats
yeah that sounds about right right so
in a way maybe it actually is a better
deal because then well i'll be honest
for it during the winter months or
something you would probably save if
you're like oh i just need it in
november
december january right 60 bucks but
it's only kind of that rational only
makes sense if bmw
is charging less for the baseline car
because you know the theory is they're
gonna their production costs go down
because they can streamline and just
make you know one version of the car
rather than have a bunch of different
kinds with the different options or
whatever
and then pass the savings on to you but
let's be real what most likely is going
to happen is they're going to charge as
much as they were before
for the version of the car without any
options and then on top of that at the
subscription fees i think the fear is
just the precedent right like this is
how it always happens where like right
yeah and halo they started charging for
maps and now dlcs are everywhere and
[ __ ] casinos they would just start
they started with this resort fee
and now everybody charges the resort fee
right when they find out they can make
money from you some way then everybody
gets on and you're [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
monthly
but also is it for you are you gonna
have drm in your car like is your heated
seat not gonna work if you don't have an
internet connection and you can't verify
that you know your subscription is up to
date yeah how else would you be able to
a lot of these cars have built in
internet
to them they have like their own
networks right but say the network goes
down so now just your your features on
your car don't work because you don't
have an internet connection
i feel like it's like if you hit it they
have satellite and [ __ ] right okay so
maybe but i will say tesla invented this
[ __ ] um
they're the original uh dlc in their
cars right right they used to they do
they sell it with like
the software on there like auto drive or
assisted driving you have to pay a
shitload of money to unlock what's
already on it but the monthly fee thing
just strikes me as kind of [ __ ] weird
bro
so there you have it though dlc is
coming to
yeah in fact i heard dlcs are coming to
toasters um
you need to pay to get the uh
very toasty setting five dollars
cam says uh in our chat he said life's a
big pay to win game
damn that's deep dude
[ __ ] that's so true
blew my mind also bmw the company is
just as douchey as the people that ride
them
wait you got a development on the free
food thing maybe so yeah zach
something from the a fuba trooper uh who
sent a timestamp where it looks like
there's a hard cut in the video when
austin's announcing everything that's
going to be free oh and they're claiming
that this is where it was cut at this
point
but i
kind of leaning towards
it's not correct because i gotta find an
up re-upload of it it's gotta be out
there yeah i did a youtube comment
search too and three months ago when the
video was released there's about four
comments that say will there be free
food at the festival
um so if people are asking then it
probably wasn't in the initial
cut you're gonna need better than this
we need the clip of them saying it
sorry ace family forever
um
all right who's my bestie this week is
it mike or
jeff last we left off you said
um jeff because jeff dm to you
and you said forget mike we're besties
for life
right right
it's all good
so here they come up again
with bradley from nelq boys who hates me
uh turn around and then
tell you they all apologized graham
stefan he was very stressed out on his
podcast i had to dm him because he
looked like he was gonna hurt himself
you know i would be like yo graham it's
all good we were just messing around and
then ethan from the popular h3 podcast
he loves you now thanks for saying
popular by the way
i like when people
hype me up like that
okay ethan thanks for throwing that in
there bro you didn't have to do that but
you did and that's what best friends do
they hype each other up yeah
for real
you know
probably wants to be friends with
oh no no he's correct he was my best
friend for like two hours and then i
guess evidently you like responded to
something or like you talk to him behind
he damned me mike
he went behind your back yeah yeah to
end our friendship so
i'm glad that they followed that though
so mike was invested in that besties two
hours of best shoe [ __ ] he's fighting
he's fighting for his life out there um
interesting and the scenes you cheated
and went behind the [ __ ] scenes
without my bro that audience over there
is also uh
intelligent but they're also very
sensitive and i was i did a little jab
at you calling you old smart man and
calling ethan
i see he's chasing his words so careful
man jeff yeah he's he's wised up very
intelligent you butter us up you call us
smart
popular
go on
what else am i jeff
younger than you and they took it as i
called them ugly i never called them
ugly never i don't think anyone really
got angry about that did they because he
said oh you're younger than him just
calling me old which is whatever right i
mean he's not the only one that makes
fun of me for looking old i think people
got angry at him for that not angry i
think we kind of goofed on him
indicating that you didn't look good for
your age or something he's kind of
trying to bait mike into talking about
it yeah yeah yeah mike didn't take the
baby absolute class act
so it's hard to say i mean there's just
such a class acting mic
jeff's really jazzing me up this episode
though it's hard to pick
ah it's hard to pick who's my bestie
maybe we'll do a poll
hmm
what olivia who's gonna get the
friendship rose right um
friendship rose or maybe you left that
yeah
you got the bff there well
we're going to get this other half of my
french necklace yeah i think i might
have [ __ ] my pants
okay interesting just don't do that when
we're hanging out bestie
got a family he looks and what did i do
you just sense that he is over they have
sound bites of me going what did i do
they have sound bites
they have another where you say who are
these goons
that's pretty generous they could have
got
could have been longer could have got
way worse [ __ ] okay bestie more
mature older guy and you're hanging out
and hide nightclubs and stuff like that
so yeah that's what i was getting at it
was more of an insult to you but his
audience man if i'm jab not somebody oh
come on just own it jeff you were
calling me old don't try to spin it
you're calling me old and it's fine i'm
not mad about it
i mean you don't have the best vision
message to be making that call come on
well he does it how can he talk about
appearance when he can't even see 2020
bro come on friendship has to be both
ways
i'm just seeing this and then i'm just
saying you got to stand by stand by your
boy here come on
an eye for an eye will make the whole
world blind dude yeah friends don't talk
about friend eyes
i'm just saying it's feedback for my
bestie
you know
what was he to make a visual
confirmation of anything that means that
i'm cool with him
there it is but now it seems like you're
trying to you're trying to retract
because you're you know you're i don't
know maybe the alpha brain i took three
alpha brains before this
and look at this i'm drinking your boys
prime right here i saw it i saw a
cardboard cut out of them and ralph's i
was walking around and i figured i'd try
this one drinking it right now yeah
at first yeah man listen bro like you
know everybody i i talked to some other
guy that made a video about the house
too people got to make money bro people
so okay this is really interesting so
let's do a poll about who's my bestie
now jeff obviously we've been through a
lot there's a lot of history between us
we've overcome a lot yeah
as friends
[Music]
certainly come to some kind of
understanding together
he called me smart and popular this
episode which is we call it our audience
smart
i just want to make sure right sure he's
but you don't think he was talking about
me no no no no no no okay well he's nice
to my friends let's say that he's nice
to my friends which goes a long way
okay
um
okay okay so that's
there anything else i'm forgetting about
jeff and the positive sure
he's cool
jeff's cool and ripped that's dope i
mean i don't know if you want to bring
in their buddies into this but cool you
know
mike
logan you have such michael scott energy
dude i swear i'm just giving all the
positive he's cool and ripped
you've had beef with logan in the past
mike's friends with logan and also
jeff's friend who you're friends with no
drove by your house in the middle of the
night so yes yes yes well we're we're
focusing on the positive not the
negative i could fill them all up for
both of them mm-hmm we're fussing we're
posed we're
focusing on the positive baby so
bff bachelor jeff whittick mike madgelek
should we have austin mcbroom in there
as a wild card
how about brown how about bradley martin
as a wild card no video too no they're
not i'm just gonna be real they're not
in the competition no no no don't put up
the poll yet because we're not done okay
okay i'm just i'm preparing i'm prepared
yes so jeff has a lot going for him
obviously and um he's kind of cool too
right he's kind of edgy which is dope
gets into a little trouble mm-hmm he's a
bad boy
he's a loyal friend too it seems like
yeah i mean he's friends with that guy
i mean he's friends with a lunatic that
just drives people's house and threatens
him and he's like yo he's my best dude
what can i do i like that energy oh jeff
jeff i thought you were talking jeff is
loyal right yeah he he loyal he loyal
but we but we love his boy okay
the piece was made
he said himself all was forgiven yeah
yeah for the stalking yeah
and now if you go if you go over to mike
let's see mike um
mike what's going on with mike what's
good about mike
um
well he overcame uh addiction and got
clean and is an inspiration to a lot of
people that's not a tip for me okay
i [ __ ] my pants today uh he's willing to
he's willing to like you know
you and him both have that like kind of
willingness to to embarrass yourselves
like like that sound bad you know
well
he was very open about [ __ ] his
pants that's something that you would
talk about if it happened to you in fact
you haven't talked about that why are
you saying that i'm willing to embarrass
myself shut
and so mike while he said actually the
thing that got this started was mike
said that
we have similar beliefs and we hype each
other up on twitter
so we have common beliefs we're both
libs
oh you're both lip uh [ __ ] lips for sure
yeah both lips
um he's working on bringing back his
hairline hairline
that might be a problem for him that i
have such a good hairline i don't know
but he's working on it you're saying
right see i don't know if his hairline's
good enough for us to be chilled oh stop
do you think he might be using you to
get his hairline back since all your
enemies lose their hair that could be a
strategy of his right oh you think but
jeff's hairline is much better so that
actually goes to jack jeff does have
grey hair yeah great be really beautiful
here yeah no
no question oh what else can we say nice
about mike um
[ __ ] as a friend he's fun he's funny he
hasn't given much of an opportunity to
be your bestie yet so
right this is new this is a new door
it's like a new exciting relationship
like a first date and you're like this
is exciting right but he's funny
um oh [ __ ] i think he's sincere in a lot
of the stuff he says very sincere
people said i don't think mike is a lib
i think he is like he is a lib he said
we have the same political belief so
he's got to be a lib i think logan's
magga i think logan and jake are mega
but jake for sure i don't know about
logan like he doesn't weigh into
political stuff very often but was it
like logan just says whatever people
want to hear
maybe maybe
ben shapiro was on uh
impulsive they had shibibo on
that isn't about by the way thank you to
um
my bestie is a cyclops oh come on
50 gifted subs that's a jeff joke
inappropriate inappropriate
how dare you
jeff is watching this man
um colleen what side of the screen is
the chat on
maybe
what
[Music]
so um god is there anything else to say
about mike um
mike michael
mike
he's a good hype man the way he [ __ ]
hypes up logan from the beginning is
nuts oh yeah he rides his dick like a
[ __ ] champ bro and i like that mike
is actually a good guy he did something
good
so
he could ride my dick really hard bruh
ride my dick like a doggy fleshlight
yeah
love that
all right so i guess that's it i mean
i'm sorry i guess i don't know mike very
well but he seems nice and funny and
look and also loyal
[Music]
um let's do a vote i guess
so it's jeff whittake mike madge like no
no wild cards in there you wanna just
i'm not gonna be friends with
bradley martin austin and bradley
they need to say one nice thing about me
and then we're besties neither of them
have said anything nice about me and
that's why jeff
and mike are in this because they say
one best thing about me and then i'm
friends with them right yeah you're easy
to win over yeah
all right well let's do it thanks
that's a good one and he has said nice
things about you mm-hmm he loves h3h3
humor yeah
actually banks is bestie material
when i met him at the airport he said
you were very smart
oh that's so nice of him to say mm-hmm i
think i forgot him had like a whole like
thing with banks though yeah
yeah he's very nice to keep they they're
both boston boys and they were going
back for the holidays and they ran into
each other at the airport and they
chatted for a while right right cam yeah
i got that right that baggage claim i
saw him getting on the airplane and i
went like whoa is that really him
because he was in first class he's a
he's a high-class guy no he's first
class
i was chatting with him at the airport
at the uh baggage claim after a red eye
so we were both very tired but he was
very kind he took the time out of his
his uh
nice guy
what can we say nice about banks what
what i mean i
i used to use his website back in the
days and i had a great time so you
talking about the gambling website look
at you now yeah yeah yeah it's not
helping that's not okay that's not
necessarily all right it's a great
website what do you mean
i just found this website
forever and he also told me to tell you
hi
he said tell me i said hi me
yeah sorry what a nice guy you know it
took seven months but what a [ __ ]
nice guy actually what up he's my he
might be my new best oh i got another
good thing about banks he ditched
keemstar
oh so good he may have done that for me
i think he probably did
sometimes keemstar things aren't that
[ __ ] deep right yeah
okay is there anything else we're not
remembering about banks let's see like i
mean that's annoying bro
i used to love the way he would
interrupt keem it was some of my
favorite content ever on the podcast it
is a loss mom's basement going away is a
lot of work
which is a positive right he hates
keemstar yeah all right well let's do
that then with with mike
jeff and blanks or banks
all right so this is my bestie
competition i would like to get all
three of these guys possibly wouldn't
that be awesome to get them in a on a
sex show together yeah we could do an
actual competition i wonder if they'd be
down
these are good sports
who's my bestie
and then maybe the winner we can go to
like disneyland together or something
well you could go on one-on-one dates
with each of them different different
places
obviously we would separate it we would
we would let this oh [ __ ] instead of a
rose i could give him a
xbox controller what's like a bro bestie
thing
a phase hat
i guess that would only work for for
banks the other two aren't phase
they don't phase out level row oliver
go to sizzler you could do friendship
bracelets
oh what's more bro though
baby
blood brothers matching xbox controllers
maybe uh give them a dog
a dog
a ducey
yeah okay let's let's do the poll guys
let's see all right i'm gonna drop in
the poll bff bachelor question mark jeff
whittick mike mash
lack and phase
[Music]
i'm so nervous right now
who am i gonna vote for oh god
don't don't say yet don't say yet okay
don't
think who i'm voting for
oh man this is crazy
there's a clear winner and i voted for
him
oh okay well that gave it away well they
have to vote before they see the results
no it doesn't work that way
jeff whittick is winning 70 my bestie
and i voted for him too because we just
have so much in common
and he's my current bestie so i get to
honor my current agreement with him
right
wow me and jeff
okay well it's a blowout
jeff friends forever bro jeff is taken
home
mike malek [ __ ] you face banks [ __ ] you
no okay
yo i'm on jeff
welcome to jeff ethan fm baby
with my new best friend ethan and jeff
show
the bra the barber and the
and the busy
he's a barber i'm a bussy
got it
very exciting stuff well there you have
it
wow jeff whittick remains to be my best
friend sorry mike
sorry to let you down you did seem
excited about those two hours that's why
you know
be gracious in victory you don't have to
say [ __ ] mike just because no no no [ __ ]
my oh my god
i only have room in my heart for one
bestie all or nothing but next week
it'll be a different person
yeah well maybe it's maybe it'll be
mike's turn who knows we'll see who says
something nice about me
it could be keemstar for all i know
i'm sorry what was that keemstar goes
you know what i like ethan he's a good
guy i and he and i'm sorry that i lied
about him all these years
i might be like bestie material probably
not though i [ __ ] hate that guy too
much it's a piece of [ __ ]
sorry keem but i don't think there's any
besties potential there it felt gross to
even say that
son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] scumbag jesus
dude calm down
you got plenty other besties like blanks
oh wait no you guys are broke up like
leafy oh wait no
now he's comparing me to hitler like who
uh
boozy
that's his butt buddy now
or ryan cavanaugh his best friend
keemstar's best friend fousey is a guy
who made a video called fouseytube's the
worst person on youtube
it tastes like beef jerky
kim has a lot of friends any any small
commentary channel that talks [ __ ] about
you he immediately swoops in that's true
it's like a justice league of
insults i'm superman
right or batman
and they're like you know
you're saying they're the legion the
crime consortium they're the legion of
doom yeah yeah we're the justice league
yeah he's not like no i'm the justice
league you can't be that's not fair you
can't be all of the justice league it is
what it is no you you said you want to
be batman you batman somebody else has
played the other one no i'm batman and
superman you can be like i don't know
you could be like um
you can't be you could be that guy with
the bow
with the bow green arrow yeah one of
those one of those
i'm
idiots
that's [ __ ] up dude
sorry dude it's just what it is
you're being really unfair right now
who do you think you are in the justice
league i don't know i just don't think
it's fair that you get to be all of
them like you're being really [ __ ]
selfish right now
that's just how i feel
is anybody else going to say anything no
he's so high and mighty right now
because he's jeff widdick's best friend
all right
that's it that's everything anybody
superman is jeff
and i'm batman i mean that's fine
i said you can be green arrow whatever
the [ __ ] that is i don't wanna be green
[ __ ] arrow
that's dc's [ __ ] that's dc's [ __ ]
uh hawkeye yeah i was saying it could be
hawkeye or you know just like whatever
dude you shoot a boat somebody said dan
is martian manhunter
that sounds kind of lame i still can't
get over what a dumb character hawkeye
is you're being invaded by like
sophisticated future ai [ __ ] robot
death robots armageddon robots and he's
fighting them with a bow and arrow yeah
and he held his own
doesn't that make it more impressive how
with the bow and arrow
i mean i've watched the movies he
made it through he got his own spin-off
and this is the first time for me and
the
universe
anyway uh moving on tana mangu we talked
about potential bestie material someone
said please go on h3 my life would be
complete thank you maddie
oh tana we should have included 10 years
who liked it hannah liked it
well yeah you've agreed to come on like
three times and you always ghost so
come on
she says dragon
she says in her description not bad
for a five with no talent self def
deprecating i like that
potential besting material i don't know
she's never said anything nice about me
that's for sure
green dante but she's been in the room
with a lot of people who [ __ ] on you and
she withheld that's true
that's true
love that for her
all right this is all this is all very
good but people are saying green dantern
you know
green danter pretty good all right you
can be green dante i'm into that
honestly
um otherwise other than that we've got
the
andrew tate on aiden ross is this worth
talking about um
honestly i found it disappointing it was
just
same it's just that his usual [ __ ]
the the schtick is like i know people
think he's hilarious but like you know
what i realized
his whole like shtick now is just doing
uh do you remember maddox
yeah back in the day yeah he's just like
that but unironically right and it but
it's like so like early 2000s humor you
[ __ ] hate kids i'll kick kids bro
kids are [ __ ] i get my energy from
the sun because i'm a man absorb rays
from the sun yeah yeah but it's not
i just don't understand why
yes so adam ross did this stream he had
like 230 000 viewers which is pretty
nuts
uh what peace and love to aiden ross i
thought his interviewing was horrible i
mean i mean with peace and love he's
just kind of fumbling around in the dark
i mean he's into a real alpha like like
he's not a real interviewer
not like me
is what you mean
yeah
thank you
i do mean that okay you've gotten good
have you seen my bill burr interview i'm
not talking about that one
i'm talking about in the last couple
years where you've you've improved by
leaps and bounds thank you dan
okay
but i just don't know why people are uh
celebrating he's getting so much
exposure recently andrew tate there's a
video of him beating the [ __ ] out of a
one like like [ __ ] scary violence
beating the [ __ ] out of a woman he was
just raided by the police for kidnapping
and human trafficking i just don't
understand why people go like he's
entertaining i want to talk to him
and like dude what are you doing
promoting this guy he's a [ __ ]
psycho i think it's like i don't think
it's yet widespread knowledge of what
a scary dude he actually is though i
think he's really popular on tick tock
and it's just like these gu it's like
alex jones i i liken it to the alex
jones thing where like people like alex
jones the meme and don't realize that
he's like
actually a psychopath that's doing
tangible harm
um
so i i don't actually
totally i mean i guess they should do
their research but we just talked about
it like a not that long ago
yeah but not everybody i mean this is a
guy who said he moved to romania because
the rape laws are boxed there yes like
that's right unironically he moved there
so he could rape people
yeah and he said that he's
not a good guy he's not but also just
google andrew tate you know
well it's not that anyone should watch
it it's super not safe for life but it's
easily accessible of him beating the
[ __ ] out of a woman in a really
disgusting
violent [ __ ] up way
and so well here i don't know it's just
kind of crazy
a lot of people think that you are a
misogynistic person now hold on let me
let me finish
i um
i think that like here's my here's my
personal what are you doing on your
phone are you okay
i'm bro i'm don't worry you can walk
okay okay um
how do i put this
dude aiden is so beta in this
such crazy beta energy coming off aiden
right now
i want to just say uh why are you afraid
to say he's a sh is a chauvinist like i
think he's proud chauvinism something is
happening in the world um and uh
it's it's uh um
matter of fact let me not do that let's
do this instead let's let's exercise
okay let me exercise my brain in your
brain um you live in romania missed i
want to hear it tell me who i'm about no
i don't think you are i don't think you
are uh mr j i don't i do not think you
are i do not think you are but when i
said i was going to do the stream with
you i got back last week but i didn't
really give a [ __ ] because people were
saying oh he's misogynist he doesn't
like girls but i don't think you are i i
don't yeah no
i i highlight the differences
interesting point he makes there
people say you hate women but i don't
think you do
was it the video of him beating the [ __ ]
out of a girl
him getting arrested for human
trafficking
um or was it him saying he moved to
romania so he could rape women
without legal repercussion between men
and women does that make me a misogynist
i don't think so
men and women are different creatures
right i agree i
yeah so i i don't think that one is even
particularly better than the other i
think we're different we operate
differently we view the world
differently that doesn't make me a
misogynistic person right
i'm a realist
so like i'm realistic so when i say [ __ ]
like girls can't drive
everyone calls me a misogynist i'm not
misogynist i'm a realist yes i get what
you're saying however
okay can i tell you something though
you can you can speak you can't tell me
anything because you're too young you
can speak and i'll listen
all right i'll speak um
i've met female drivers that are really
good at driving you know what i'm saying
an exception does not miss
anyway it's kind of a whole [ __ ] two
hours of that
but
they're making it's like when you make
like a nazi palatable palatable
um
it's really [ __ ] up and i really mean
that
when you i mean joe rogan did this a lot
with like gavin
mcguinness yeah and alex jones and alex
jones where it's just like oh he's just
goofy he's just funny he's even today
which is like yeah they can be funny
like i think donald trump's really
[ __ ] funny doesn't mean that he's not
a [ __ ] monster he is
yeah it's crazy because even recently
joe rogan's like alex is a good guy and
he's right about a lot of stuff you know
watching the january 6th commission yeah
alex jones is like we're going to storm
the capital and f and we're going to
[ __ ] take it like he is a psycho
a violent psychopath
dude what a loving liberal
here's andrew tate
quote
from 2017 secondly harvey creep
obviously but women have been exchanging
sex for opportunity
for a very long time some did this they
were not abused okay whatever that's not
the worst thing he said by a mile
uh basically he leads on to say that if
you put yourself in the position then
you need to take some of the
responsibility
um
[Music]
where's the part where he was like
oh my god bro wait what
wait what
point 7.3 million views what is this
clip
hold on
it's me and mars
you and brittany talk making fun of him
7.3 million holy [ __ ] dude people love
andrew tate interesting
no i mean a man can only they'd love to
hate him too i guess
a million likes
yeah it's we it's our club
oh this is our clip yeah yeah oh yeah
awesome
got it got it got it
i thought this was his clip i thought
this was like a gym talk about me being
a beta who hates exercising
okay wow look at us we got we went viral
on tick tock let's go
someone else if i have a woman who i
truly love and i go out and [ __ ] and i
come back to her and i don't care about
her and i only love my girl that's not
cheating
that's not cheating
i'm speechless it's exercise
if she even talks to a dude is cheating
because females are emotionally invested
i have no emotional investment so no
he's like i'm not even emotionally
invested in my girlfriend to be honest
exactly
yeah no
oh it's fine i love that it was very
very clear any woman who was with me
never never even the only men they spoke
to besides me were my brother hai
and the guys online who were paying them
that is it they were absolutely loyal
amen yeah that okay that's interesting
yeah a lot of people do hate him
obviously
but this stuff like ayden ross has a lot
of young
i would say young men watching young or
boys even
and he's just not his behavior the way
he talks about women
the way he talks about life is
so [ __ ] horrible message
it's scary to see the com the top
comments on his video on uh aiden's
video all in support of
tate yeah of course because it's
aiden is not really capable of
challenging him in a meaningful way and
he ends up just making him look cool
no problems intrinsically with females
doing only fans like
if if men are stupid enough this this
preceding him saying he's not a
chauvinist watch this buy this [ __ ] then
women should certainly sell it and make
a bunch of money more power to them i'm
a i'm a feminist i believe in empowering
women make as much money as you can yeah
sure be be do only fans like my [ __ ]
i wouldn't i wouldn't even mind my girl
doing only fans as long as i kept all
the money
i wouldn't give a [ __ ] i had a girl said
i won't do only fans i'm like cool go
for it let me know how much money we
make
you're keeping all of it though
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes she's mine oh they're
gonna cancel they're going to cancel
like i don't think you're solving this
that's totally reasonable thing to say
so me watch me give a [ __ ] come on don't
be a [ __ ] say it
all right
i hear i hereby um want to go back to
what i said and i want to uh rebuttal it
and i want to say that uh i this i
should have not
given my two cents in this argument and
stay out of it and that uh
the uh the thing is that um i believe
that
um if if if something if something is
yours you should be getting all profits
of it
that was weak but i'll let it slide
thank you
it was weak though
but i want all the people all the
feminists watching who want to go cancel
people go cancel this guy because i can
tell he gives a [ __ ] don't try and
cancel me why i don't want a [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
and when they're doing sick he's not the
thing is andrew's not joking though when
he says as long as she gives me all the
money he literally has women [ __ ]
kidnapped and enslaved and human
trafficked in his compound in romania
doing webcams for him and paying him
like that's actually happening that's
what's so crazy about andrew tay
it's not shtick that's that's really
what he does
super interesting isn't it like
it's not an act
yeah the whole shtick that aiden's doing
with him
is really [ __ ] up it's so weird yeah
once again i feel like aidan just
involved in something that has no idea
what he's doing you know he's trying to
do stick but doesn't realize the
significance same thing with the whole
stake situation yeah exactly he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's just just
and at the very least i think twitch
should do something about it because
dude ross is 21 years old he's you might
say he's stupid or whatever because he's
young sure uh and in that case twitch
should remove it um i don't think that
that's safe content for people i really
don't
um you wanted there was more good parts
there i think so
if it's what i remember
yeah let me pull it's like a rant about
getting cancelled
yeah let's go
believe that
um if if i go cancel people go cancel
this guy because i can tell he gives a
[ __ ] don't try and cancel me why i don't
a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
there cancel me i do not care i don't
care i exist outside of the matrix no
one can damage me doesn't matter you can
i don't even have a [ __ ] account when
you do ban me i don't even have an
account i do
what is he man this guy he's an assault
he is a homogenous
can't believe what he said what are you
doing
misogynistic feminists it's people like
him that are keeping women back that's
the reason you don't have high-paying
jobs
andrew
it's 100 this guy i can't believe you're
saying this bro
what the [ __ ]
sorry stick um yeah yeah
yeah i mean he he's right he he isn't
cancelable and
well yeah like obviously
yeah he's openly a criminal and
he's uh
you know his popularity is based on him
saying outrageous things so he's not
gonna get canceled for saying outrageous
things but the whole like
i exist outside of the matrix i don't
even have an account it's like
embarrassing
bro you're you're all over tik tok he's
on twitter
uh
you know suspended from twitter but yeah
i think he's back i saw him tweeting oh
he must have a new account then yeah i
think it's in a he's doing he's doing
the keemstar where it's not loophole
yeah um but it's like he's he's
completely [ __ ] plugged in and you
know his whole like thing right now is
selling
man lessons or whatever does he have
like a subscription thing yeah he sells
like man university he's like a
self-help guy
it's like bro you you are
you are so plugged in like you are so in
the [ __ ] matrix you don't and you
don't even [ __ ] realize it you know
who's not in the matrix ted kaczynski
[ __ ] right exactly go live off the grid
if you want to be outside of the system
that's my [ __ ] boy that's right if
that's the real red pill alpha right
there yeah you make you make a living
selling self-help to
gullible people you're you're not really
he's just the longest i know you're not
really like the [ __ ] uh
you know individualist scion that he
thinks he is oh this is his website tate
university
tate university by the way just to tell
you any self-help person is scamming you
yeah or if they're all liars every self
health person is a liar and a con man
period there's no exception
i know some people probably hate to hear
that i don't think there's any single
exception to that
they're all [ __ ]
i don't think you can even get
my philosophy is oh yeah you can't even
get a useful lesson
from a person like this because you
don't really learn anything until you
experience it and then
it can influence how your choices go
before but if someone tells you
something like
women are this way and that way and then
it's like it's not going to actually
affect your personality in a real way
because you have to experience [ __ ]
it's all a scam what do you got here
he posted this yeah he paid somebody to
make a comic about himself beating up
spider-man for being beta saab sniff
spider-man what the [ __ ]
i came home and
saw a fancy sports car in front of my
house when i went inside some [ __ ]
named tristan was banging my girl is
that his brother how's his brother yeah
you're a punk ass [ __ ] what there's not
even a punch line
yeah we're not talking we're not talking
about uh
part two and three are in discord
oh are there's pages to this
so stupid
and this is this is really it isn't it i
mean this guy it's not just that he has
a mentality of a child he he is a child
like he sees himself as a comic book
villain
like unironically spending money on
paying some really untalented artists
but he does the things that he actually
does the evil things
crunch whip
sick bro
by the way he was not really a
successful mma fighter
was he i think he got his ass beat i
remember when we talked about before
some people that yeah and then they said
that he had a fairly decent round yeah
he had a mixed record that's right
wasn't it kickboxing not mma or maybe he
did both i don't know you're pathetic
get the [ __ ] out of here
tristan i owe you a car wow bro is that
[ __ ] rad dude
this is a nine-year-old this is a nice
nine-year-old
people who like make weird
like psychosis field comics in their
basement
so there you go turn your life around
financially become financially free
person
wow that's a big offer
are you stuck in a nine-to-five job or
worse never enough money because
inflation okay
feel like you can't pursue your dreams
your do you live in a country with
extreme rape laws oh that's not there
that's a later lesson
i believe it was this website that on
the internet he took it down but it's on
the
way back machine
that he
basically
brags about being a sex trafficker and
it's since been removed but that that
was uh oh yes that was on his website
yeah
okay what's up guys i thought let's give
a quick review on hustlers university
part two now like you i was probably um
i was very skeptical at the first
because
i've seen a few videos
when i saw that he was doing a course
it's kind of like i was exactly
like i would expect somebody that pays
for hustler university look like cool
you probably are as well but i've been
after one month um pleasantly surprised
i think this course is amazing what's
different is is i'm gonna say the first
thing i think this is the most important
thing to remember is that this isn't
necessarily just one course it's a group
of people so if you get stuck have you
shut up
yeah do you have that testimonial it
really was on his website you're right
yeah i'm gonna look for it
you know what i think we had an old dock
when we first talked about it how much
is it i wonder if i can pick it up
50 bucks a month that's that's
reasonable
chet's saying the guy in that video
looks like you dan
oh [ __ ] bro what
but they say that about everybody they
said about it yeah so is that dog yeah
[ __ ] though that's kind of brutal
anyway another thing a bff's again it's
like
not sure how to describe tomorrow's
episode andrew tape but it certainly was
interesting i mean again he's just
becoming like
a fun character to have on your podcast
and i'm just not sure about all that
like
at some point someone being entertaining
or funny is not enough to warrant them
platform like dude you guys got to see
him beating the [ __ ] out of that woman
it's on the internet
you can't
you there you got to take some
responsibility in who you [ __ ]
platform
it's just
do you know what i mean like
there's enough people watching that are
going to think he's funny or cool or not
serious
but there it is andrew tate ladies and
gentlemen is striking a
mainstream fame
um
[Music]
yeah if you want to know what
your brain is on andrew tate that's what
happened to god greek god x for sure
anyway whatever that's it anything else
guys
uh
no leftovers tomorrow
remember
tomorrow morning
is the teddy fresh sale
at 10 a.m pst
so if you guys want some 50 off
get out there because it's probably
gonna go pretty fast
i'm sorry dan what were you saying
i don't remember it wasn't important
so here it is we got the world as a
dumpster fire so everything is 50 off
sale begins at 17 hours baby
except for the gentle thrills
which is the one that just came out
about everything else including this
shirt i'm wearing now oh miss you oh
miss yeah so yeah that's that's fun
exciting for anyone who wants some teddy
spread
well
go ahead i'm sorry i'm just going to say
because a lot of new members don't know
because we're being gifted so many new
memberships if you were given a
membership you could watch all the
behind the scenes now on the channel
there's a playlist we have about 30 of
them we have majority of them wow good
job man thank you
uh
i don't think there's a playlist i think
that's a lie
i think you just told a lie i'm a filthy
liar well i just went to the community
you can make one i think if you go to
the community tab
oh yeah i'm sorry dan
everybody document this
i was ready i was right for once members
only videos it's one of those self-made
playlists oh it's like auto generation
auto generated oh that's cool well there
you go there is a playlist
yeah lots of work yes stuff back there
for members um
we do one a week that abe produces
that's pretty good stuff there
exclusive stuff also we're going to be
doing a live viewing soon of uh
tiptoes tippy toes
right you had said potentially this
weekend is that still a thing
i don't know
well are you guys available because you
guys gave up your last weekend too so i
don't want to uh that's true i don't
want to push you guys
that's true this weekend i have
i can't speak for everyone but i'm down
i think we may have plans as a crew next
not this weekend but next weekend so
maybe we should do it this weekend if
everyone can
okay let's i'll let you guys know on
friday if we're gonna do uh
the tippy toes viewing this weekend
cool it would be fun i love that [ __ ] i
can't wait to watch that movie the role
of a lifetime
gary all of a lifetime
all right well thanks for watching
everybody happy wednesday my dudes
we will be back on friday for after dark
and um close out the week
katie cat meow thank you for
oh i think five to twenty we're about to
end but i think i found it i pulled up
yeah
i believe
this is the page me was that me it's
like right now oh sorry sorry
[Music]
oh yeah here it is my job is to get
women to fall in love with me literally
that was my job my job is to meet girls
go on a few dates sleep with her test if
she's quality get her to fall in love
with me to where she'll do anything i
say and then get her on webcam so we
become rich together whether you agree
or disagree with what i did with their
loyalty submission and love for me
doesn't matter you cannot reject the
results and the results are simple my
girlfriends would do more for me than 99
of men's wives would do for them blah
blah blah what i learn in this job
so yeah this has all been scrubbed from
his website but this is basically him
that was his selling bragging about i
recruit women into sex work yeah i love
he's like yeah no they stay they stay
they pay me willingly and they just stay
here not by force or anything right yeah
they just love me
yeah what's not to love about uh cobra
there it is thank you everybody we'll
see you on friday have a good week uh
until then and god bless we'll be uh
hanging out and shout out to my best
friend
jeff widdick
hope you're having a great day buddy
[Applause]
bye guys
[Music]
bye